hey everyone this is keith sinha from
sinclair learn welcome to this video on
microsoft is your full course in this
full course we will learn everything
about azure in detail with an
introduction to what microsoft is here
is
then we will look into its concepts in
detail
our experts will give you a quick
training on azure services
moving forward we will understand as
your machine learning as your active
directory and as your virtual network
after that we will be looking into few
major differences between aws and azure
and then we will have a quick
understanding of how the famous cloud
providers aws azure and gcp are
different from each other
finally we will conclude this video by
discussing the top 25 important as your
interview questions and answers for
beginners and experience level
candidates
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your azure related queries
would have been answered
for this training with me i have our
experienced azure expert sam
rahul and alan karl together we will
take you to the various topics of azure
so let's start with an exciting video on
the microsoft azure cloud provider
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon
never miss an update from simply learn
hi guys this is raul from simply learn
and today we'll be talking about one of
the fastest growing and second largest
cloud computing platform in the market
right now i'm talking about microsoft
azure now before we begin let's talk
about what we'll be covering in this
video first we'll talk about why you
should be interested in cloud computing
what exactly is cloud computing what is
microsoft is your some of its services
and the uses of azure now let's start
with why you should be interested in
cloud computing now let's say you have
an idea for a revolutionary application
an idea that ticks both the boxes when
it comes to good applications one it has
great user experience and two it'll be
highly profitable now for it to be
successful you'll have to release it on
the internet people need to use it they
need to spread the word and then it'll
become truly famous however for that
you're going to need servers storage
developers a dedicated network and
application security to ensure your
application works the way it does now
these are a lot of components and that's
where the problem lies there are two
major disadvantages to this approach the
initial setup is very expensive and
risky which means this requires a huge
amount of capital up front to ensure
that it works properly and the downside
is if your application does not become
famous or it doesn't return as much as
you expect it to you're probably not
going to get the money back which means
it provides a huge amount of risk and
then on the flip side if it does become
famous your number of users have
increased which means that you'll have
to buy more servers and storage systems
to keep up with your demand and this
problem can be solved with the help of
cloud computing now that you know why
you should be interested in cloud
computing let's go into the details of
what exactly is cloud computing now
cloud computing is basically a platform
that gives you access to a number of
computing resources and this is possible
with the help of the internet now as a
user all you need to do is go to a cloud
service provider through your laptop or
your computer through the internet of
course connect to that cloud service
provider and then there you go you have
access to computing resources now
computing resources may include you know
serverless computing virtual machines
storage and so much more now let's dig a
little deeper now basically these cloud
service providers actually have massive
data centers now in these data centers
what you have are hundreds of servers
also included are storage systems and
mainly several organizations critical
components so these are very secure safe
locations where a large amount of data
is stored hence the name data centers
now it is to these data centers that
users actually connect to collect their
data or use it so actually users can
access any service based on the
requirement now like i told you there's
a number of services the user can use
for example now if you want a
notification every time someone sends
you a message or perhaps once you get an
email you need a copy of it created now
for all of this there are services and
most importantly almost every cloud
service provider has this option where
users only pay for the service that they
use so there's no charge up front where
they tell you that you need to pay x
amount of money so that you can use our
services you're only paying for the
amount of time that you're using these
services now cloud computing is used for
a wide variety of reasons firstly
there's machine learning and data
analysis now basically there are
services that analyze your data and tell
you how you can work with this data
better then there's data storage in
backup streaming media content for
example did you know that the shows that
you watch on netflix actually all of
them are in the cloud so you're
connected to the internet and you browse
through netflix and you get access to
the videos these are possible with the
help of cloud service providers this
creating and testing applications
automating software delivery which is a
component in devops and hosting blogs
and applications
so now what is azure what's the big
cloud service provider all about so
azure is a cloud computing platform
provided by microsoft now it's basically
an online portal through which you can
access and manage resources and services
now resources and services are nothing
but you know you can store your data and
you can transform the data using
services that microsoft provides again
all you need is the internet and being
able to connect to the azure portal then
you get access to all of the resources
and their services in case you want to
know more about how it's different from
its rival which is aws i suggest you
click on the top right corner and watch
the aws versus your video so that you
can clearly tell how both these cloud
service providers are different from
each other now here are some things that
you need to know about this year it was
launched in february 1st 2010 which is
significantly later than when aws was
launched it's free to start and has a
pay-per-use model which means like i
said before you need to pay for the
services you use through azure and one
of their most important selling points
is that 80 percent of fortune 500
companies use azure services which means
that most of the bigger companies of the
world actually recommend using azure and
then azure supports a wide variety of
programming languages the c-sharp
node.js java and so much more another
very important selling point of zero is
the amount of data centers it has across
the world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now azure
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54. now let's talk
about azure services now azure services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute and machine learning integration
management tools identity devops web and
so much more you're going to have a hard
time trying to find a domain that azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover it
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of linux or windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add ram you can decrease ram you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a match of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
his ear all you need is to provide the
code to azure and it will execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking services first up we have
azure cdn or the content delivery
network now the azure cdn service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have express r
now with this you can actually connect
your on-premise network onto the
microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on-premise
network and the service that you want
then you have virtual network now with
virtual network you can have any of the
azure services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azure dns so azure
dns is a hosting service which allows
you to host their dns or domain name
system domains in azure so you can host
your application using azure dns now for
the storage services first up we have
disk storage with this storage you are
given a cost effective option of
choosing hdd or solid state drives to go
along with your virtual machines based
on your requirements then you have blob
storage now this is actually optimized
to ensure that they can store massive
amounts of unstructured data which can
include text data or even binary data
next you have file storage which is a
managed file storage and can be
accessible via the smb protocol or the
server message block protocol and
finally you have queue storage now with
queue storage you can provide durable
message queuing for an extremely large
workload and the most important part is
that this can be accessed from anywhere
in the world now let's talk about how
azure can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like i mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual machines of any size or
ram that you want you can integrate in
sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and you have virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored i'm
sam an azure cloud architect working for
simply learn and i'm more than glad to
walk you through this session where
we're gonna talk about azure in great
length and breadth and if you're looking
for a video that talks and walks you
through all the services in azure then
this could be one of the best video you
could find in the internet and without
any further delay let's get started
everybody like story is it so let's get
started with the story in a city not so
far away a ceo had plans to expand his
company globally and called one of his
id personnel for an i.t opinion and this
guy has been in the company for a long
time and is very seasoned with the
company's infra and he nicely answered
the questions with what he foresaw and
he said i have a good news and a bad
news for us to go global and he starts
with the good news he said sir we're
well on our way to become one of the
world's largest shipping company and the
bad news is however our data centers
have almost run out of space and setting
up new ones around the world would be
too expensive and very time consuming
now the it personal let's call him mike
now he explains the situation from how
he saw it but the ceo had done some
homework about how he was going to do it
and he answered mike saying don't worry
about that mic i've come up with a
solution for a problem and it's called
microsoft azure well mike is an hard
working and honest i.t professional
working for that company but he did not
spend time on learning the latest
technologies and he asked this question
very honestly oh how does it solve a
problem and the ceo begins to explain
azure to mike and he starts with what is
cloud computing and then he goes on and
talks about azure and the service is
offered by azure and why azure is better
than the other cloud providers and what
are the great companies that uses azure
and how they got benefited out of it and
then he winds it all up with the use
cases of azure so he begins his
explanation saying microsoft azure is
known as the cloud service provider and
it works on the basis of cloud computing
now microsoft azure is formerly known as
windows azure and it's a microsoft's
public cloud computing platform it also
provides a range of cloud services
including some of them are compute
analytics storage and networking we can
always pick and choose from these
services to develop and scale our
applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
cloud microsoft azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing azure services offered by
azure how is azure
leading when compared to other cloud
service providers and what are the
companies that are using azure let's
talk about that in simple terms cloud
computing is being able to access
compute services like servers storage
database networking software analytics
intelligence and lot more over the
internet which is the cloud with the
flexibility of the resources that we use
like anytime i wanted reserves i can use
one and it becomes available immediately
and any time if i want to retire and
resource i can simply retire as a
service and not pay for it and we also
typically pay only for the services that
we use and this helps greatly with our
operating cost to run our infrastructure
more efficiently and scale our
environment up or down depending on the
business needs and changes and all the
servers and storages and databases and
networking all that are accessed through
the network of remote systems or remote
computers hosted in the internet
typically in the provider's data center
which is azure in this case now we don't
use any physical server or an
on-premises server here well we still
use physical servers and vms you know
hosted on a hardware or a physical
server but they're all in the provider's
environment and none of them sit on
premises or in our data center we only
access them remotely it looks and feels
the same except for the fact that they
are in a remote location we access them
remotely do all the work remotely and
when we're done we can shut it down and
not pay for them so some of the use
cases some of the use cases of cloud
computing are creating applications and
services the other use cases are storing
or using cloud for storage alone
if there is one thing that ever grows in
our organization is the storage every
new day there is a new storage
requirement and it's very dynamic it's
very hard to predict and if we go out
and buy a big storage capacity up front
until we use the storage capacity fully
the empty storages you know we're
wasting money on them so instead i can
go for a storage which scales
dynamically that's in the cloud put
storage or put data in the cloud and pay
only for what you're storing and for the
next month if you have deleted or
flushed out some files or data pay less
for it so it's a very dynamic storage in
the cloud and a lot of companies are
getting benefited from storing data in
the cloud because of its uh dynamic in
nature and the cost that comes along
with it the cheap cost that comes along
with it and also they give a lot of the
providers like azure they give a data
application for free they promise an sla
along with the data we store in the
cloud so there's an sla attached to it
and they also provide data recoveries as
well if in case something goes wrong
with the physical disk where our data is
stored azure automatically makes our
data available from the redundant or
other places where it had stored our
data because of the sla they wanted to
keep the other use case for azure is
hosting websites and running blogs using
the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of
cdn
content delivery network which allows us
to stream a video or audio files with
great speed you know with that with
azure our audio or video application
works seamlessly because they are
provided to the client with very low
latency and that improves the customer
experience for our application azure
compute service is a good place for
delivering software on demand there are
a lot of software's embedded softwares
that we can buy using azure and
everything on a pay-as-you-go service
model so anytime we need a software we
can go out and immediately buy the
software for the next one r or 2r let's
say and use them and then return it back
we're not bound to any yearly licensing
cost by that
azure computing services has analytic
available for us with which we can
analyze get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network be it logs
be the performance be the metrics you
know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over
the heaps and heaps of logs that we have
saved azure analytics services helps us
to get a good visual of what's going on
in the network where have we dropped
where have we increased or what's
causing what's the major driver what is
the top 10 errors that we get in the
server in the application stuff like
that those can be easily gathered from
the azure analytic services
now cloud is really a very cool term for
the internet a good analogy would be
looking back any time we look at a
diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a mail gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country a lot of things
happening in between from the time you
hit the send button and the time the
other person hits the real button right
and we the simple and the easiest way of
putting it in a picture is simply draw a
cloud and on the one end one person will
be sending the email and on the other
end the other person will be reading the
email so a cloud is a really cool term
for the internet now that's some basics
about cloud computing now that we've
understood about cloud computing in
general let's talk about microsoft azure
as a cloud service
now microsoft azure is a set of cloud
services to build
manage and deploy applications on a
network with the help of microsoft
azure's frameworks now microsoft azure
is a computing service created by
microsoft basically for building testing
deploying and managing applications and
services through a global network of
microsoft managed data centers now
microsoft azure provides sas which is
software as a service and pass which is
platform as a service and iaas
infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
microsoft specific and third-party
software
now let me pick and talk about a
specific service for example management
azure automation provides a way for us
to automate the manual long running and
frequently repeated tasks that are
commonly performed tasks both in cloud
and enterprise environment it saves us a
lot of time and increases the
reliability and it kind of gives a good
administrative control and even
schedules the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis
to give you a quick history of microsoft
azure it was launched on first february
and it was awarded or it was called an
industry leader for infrastructure and
platform as a service by a gartner now
gartner is the world's leading research
and advisory company this microsoft
azure supports a number of programming
languages like c sharp java and python
all these cool services we get to use
and pay only for how much we use for
example if we use for an r we only get
to pay for an r even the costliest
system available and if you use them for
an r we only pay for that particular r
and then we're done no more billing on
the resource that we have used a
microsoft azure has spread itself more
than 50 regions around the world so it's
quite easy for us to pick a region and
it will start provisioning and running
our applications probably from day one
because the infrastructure and the tools
and technologies needed to run our
application are already available all
that we have to do is commit the code in
that particular region or build an
application and launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of in
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their
request will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center
near
each customer location because of the
cost involved but with azure it's
possible azure already has data centers
around the world and all that we have to
do is just pick a data center build an
environment there they are available
starting day one number one and also the
cost is considerably saved because we
are using a public cloud instead of an
physical infrastructure to serve those
customers from a very local location and
the services that azur is offering is
ever increasing as of now as we speak we
have like 200 plus services offered and
they span through different domain or
different platform or different
technologies available within the azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by azure
let's now talk about different services
and azure starting with artificial
intelligence plus machine learning where
we have a lot of tools and technologies
so the wide variety of services
available on azure includes artificial
intelligence plus machine learning plus
analytic services to get and or to give
us a good visual of how the data or how
the application is performing or the
type of the category of data stored and
to read from the logs and variety of
compute services different vms with
different size and different operating
systems different containers available
different type of databases available
a lot of developer tools that are
available for us
an identity service to
manage our users in the azure cloud and
those users can be integrated or
federated with let's say google
facebook you know linkedin so there are
some external federation services they
can be used to integrate with our
identity system iots iot services iot
tools and technologies available and
management tools to manage the users you
know creating identity is one and then
managing them on top of it is a totally
different thing and we have tools
technologies to manage the users
cool services for data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
technologies available for mobile
application development and i can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking services i can implement my
own security both azure provider and
third-party security services on azure
cloud that's now possible and a lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in azure
cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones
the azure compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or linux via
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options azure provides for us
to migrate our vms to azure and lot more
and these compute services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or in on premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are virtual machines and this
azure virtual machines
gives us the ability to develop and
manage a virtual computer environment or
a virtualized environment inside azure's
cloud environment that too in a virtual
private network now we will talk about
virtual private network at a later point
but as of now just i know that there are
a lot of services available in azure
compute servers that we can get
benefited from we can always choose from
a very wide range of compute options for
example you know we have an option to
choose the operating system we have the
option to choose whether the system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on-premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
software attached to it or do we want to
go and buy the operating system from the
cloud from azure marketplace and these
are just a few of the options available
for us when we want to buy the compute
environment and these computer
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our vm instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pay for what we use model
meaning there is no upfront cost we use
the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there is no
literal long-term
commitment when it comes to using
virtual machines in the cloud and these
most of the services are built on a
pay-per-minute billing basis all right
and at no point because of the
pay-per-minute billing model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's attractive isn't
it now let's talk about batch service
now bad service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or linux it's going to run fairly well
and with bad servers we can take
advantage of the environment's unique
features and not only that in short the
batch service helps us to manage the
whole batch environment and also it
helps to schedule the jobs now this
azure batch service is actually runs on
a large scale parallel and high
performance computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in azure
and when we run bad services this azure
batch creates a pool of computer nodes
and installs the needed applications
that we want to run and then it
schedules jobs to those individual nodes
in those pools as a customer there is no
need for us to install a cluster or
there is no need for us to install a
software that actually could use the
jobs or even to manage or even to scale
those infrastructure are the software
because everything is managed by azure
and this batch service is a platform as
a service there is no additional charge
for using this batch service except for
i mean the only charges that we'll be
paying is for the virtual machines that
the service uses and the storage that we
will be using of course and the
networking services that we would be
using for this batch service let's
summarize this batch service we have a
choice of operating system that we can
pick and use and it scales by itself now
the alternative for the batch would be
queues but in queues we'll have to
pre-provision and pay for the
infrastructure even if we're not using
it but with a batch
we only pay for what we use and this bad
service helps us to manage the
application manage the scheduling as a
whole as if they are just one thing as
next thing in the compute domain let's
talk about this fabric service now this
fabric service is actually a distributed
system platform that helps us to package
deploy and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex
infrastructure problems and they can
focus only on implementing workloads or
taking care of their development taking
care of their application instead of
spending time on infrastructure so what
service fabric service fabric it
provides runtime capabilities and life
cycle management two applications that
are composed of micro services no
infrastructure management at all and
with service fabric we can easily scale
the application to tens or hundreds or
even to thousands of machines here
machines represent containers as next
thing in compute domain let's talk about
virtual machine scale set now this
virtual machine scale set it lets us to
create a group of identical load
balanced vms i just want to mention it
again it helps us to manage a group
identical and load balanced vms the
number of instances or the number of vm
instances in an in a scale set can
increase or decrease
in response to uh the demand or in
response to a schedule that we define
you know the resources needed on a
monday morning is not the same as that
would be required on a saturday or a
sunday morning all right and even within
the day the resources that would be
needed in the beginning of the business
hour is not the resources that would be
needed at noon or you know after eight
or nine
in the evening so the demands could
actually vary in the environment and the
skill set helps us to take care of the
varying demand or
take care of the different
infrastructure requirement at a
different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
high availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
vms as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine scale set just like i said this
virtual machine skill set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes the request to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set it helps
us to create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one and with
skill set we can increase or decrease
the virtual machines with virtual
machine scale set we can centrally
manage and configure and update a big
group of vms and it's a great use case
when it comes to big data or container
workloads as next thing in compute
domain uh let's talk about cloud
services now this azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that support
scalability or an application that
requires scalability or reliability and
and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so azure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a vm but it's a platform as a
service vms are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
vm through cloud service it becomes
platform
as a service so here is how you got to
be thinking with infrastructure as a
service like vms we first create and
configure the environment and then we
run applications on top of it let's look
at the responsibility the responsibility
for us in vm is that we manage
everything end to end like uh you know
deploying new patches picking the
versions of the operating system and
making sure they are intact and all that
stuff it's all managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
i mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform i mean manage the platform
not as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by azure
like deploying new versions of the
operating system it's all handled by the
azure so we deploy the application and
we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
uh where we can uh
write the uh application code and we
don't have to worry about hardware
simply hand over the code and cloud
service takes care of it so no worry on
the hardware at all so responsibilities
like patching what do we do if something
crashes how do i update the
infrastructure how do i manage
the maintenance or the downtime in the
underlying infrastructure all that is
handled by azure it also provides a good
testing environment for us you know we
can simply run the code test it before
it's actually released to the production
i want to expand a bit on these testing
applications so this azure cloud service
it actually gives us an staging
environment for testing a new release
without it affecting the existing
release which actually reduces
the customer downtime so we can run the
application test it and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging environment where
we can add more to it and then swap it
back at a later point so it kind of
gives us unswappable environment for
testing our applications and not only
that it gives us health monitoring
alerts it helps us to monitor the health
and availability of our application and
there is a dashboard we can benefit from
when we use azure cloud services and
that shows the key statistics all in one
place and we can also set up real-time
alerts to one when a service
availability or a certain metrics that
we are concerned about degrades as next
thing in compute domain let's talk about
functions now functions are serverless
computing many times if you heard about
azure being serverless a lot of time
they are referencing or the person who's
talking to you is referencing to
serverless computing or azure functions
which is a serverless computing service
hosted on microsoft azure the main
motive of
a function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without
we need to pre-provision or manage any
azure infrastructure so azure functions
are script or a piece of code that gets
run in response to an event that you
want to handle so in short we can just
write a code that you need for a problem
at hand without actually worrying about
the whole application or the
infrastructure that will be running
that code and the best of all the best
is when we use functions we only pay for
the time that our code runs
so what does functions provide or what
does azure functions provide azure
functions allow users to build
applications using serverless
simple functions with a programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c-sharp f-sharp node.js java and php
so here we really don't have to worry
about provisioning or maintaining
servers if a code requires more resource
yes azure functions handles or it
provides the additional resources needed
by the court and the best part is we
only pay for the amount of time the
functions are running not the resources
but the amount of time the function is
running as next thing and moving to the
new domain let's talk about the
container domain in azure now the
container domain or the container
service it allows us to quickly deploy a
production ready kubernetes or a docker
swamp cluster now what's a container a
container is a standard unit of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies so the applications run
quickly and reliably from one computing
environment to another it could be a
testing uh to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production are on premises to
cloud or one cloud to another cloud vice
versa now imagine we had an option not
to worry about the vm and just focus on
the application well that's exactly
what containers helps us achieve so
these container instances enable us to
focus on applications and not worrying
about managing vms or not worrying about
the learning the new tools required to
manage the vms or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers they can be
deployed into the cloud using a single
command if you're using command line
interface and
a couple of button clicks if we are
using the azure portal and these
containers are kept lightweight but they
are equally secure as virtual machines
let's talk about container services next
thing the container service or
sometimes called as azure kubernetes
service it helps us to manage the
containers container is one thing and a
service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or acs it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this azure container
service or acs it it actually provides a
way to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configured to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple ssh tunnel into them and
this acs when it runs application it
runs applications from docker images
what does that mean a docker images
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and acs also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using aks or acs is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is made simple using this container
services and even training of model
using a large data set in a complex and
resource intensive environment this aks
helps us to simplify that environment
all right as next thing in container
domain let's talk about container
registry we spoke about registry a
little bit when we spoke about docker
images so container registry is a single
place where we can store our images
which are docker images when we use when
we use containers it's it's docker
images that we use for our image
purposes so these container images are a
central registry that can be used to
ease container development by easing the
storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like
docker swamp or the images used in
docker swamp are in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for jio replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now these jio replication it
actually enables us to manage global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
global deployments as one entity because
we are jio replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout
the global
replication centers we would have set up
and so just one editing would have
actually edited the global images and
those global images would have
provisioned at the global application so
one edit replication and then
provisioning of the applications
global wide and this replication also
helps us to
helps us network latency because you
know anytime an application needs to
deploy it does not have to rely on a
single source which which can be reached
only through high latency network
because we have global replications
around the world anytime the application
wants to check back it would check back
uh the application which is in a very
nearby location for the application
itself global replication means that we
are managing it as a single entity
that's being replicated across the
multiple regions in the globe as next
thing in our learning let's talk about
azure databases now these azure
databases are
rational in fact they have many flavors
in them we're going to look at different
flavors so sql nosql cache type of
database that azure offers so we're
going to learn one at a time or we're
going to learn one by one so this azure
sql database is a rational database in
fact it's a rational database as a
service it's managed by azure we don't
get to do a lot of management in it so
it's a regional database as a service
based on microsoft
sql
server database engine and this database
is a high performance database it's very
reliable and
it's very secure as well and this high
reliability high performance and for
this high security really don't have to
do anything it comes along with it and
it's managed by azure and there are two
things that i definitely need to mention
about azure sql database that is it's an
intelligent service number one it's
fully managed by azure and it also has
this one good thing which is it has
built-in intelligence that learns app
patterns and adapts to maximize
performance and reliability and data
protection of the application that's
something that's not found in
many of the other cloud providers that
i'm aware of so i thought i'll mention
it so it uses built-in intelligence to
learn about the user's database patterns
and helps improve performance and
protection and migration or importing
data is very easy when it comes to azure
sql database so it can be readily or
immediately used for analytic reporting
and
intelligent applications in azure as
next thing let's talk about azure
cosmodb now azure cosmodb is a database
service that
is for nosql type and
it's it's created to provide low latency
and
an application that scales dynamically
or that scales rapidly
now this azure cosmodb is an
a globally distributed service
and it's a multi-model
database this can be provisioned in a
click of a button that's all we got to
do if we need to provision and azure
cosmodb in the azure it helps with
scaling the database now we can
elastically and independently scale
throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and
it provides or
azure promises a comprehensive sla that
no other database can offer that's the
best part about cosmodb so this cosmodb
was built with a global distribution in
mind and it's built
with the horizontal scale in mind and
all this we can use by only paying for
what we have used and remember the
difference between azure cosmodb and the
sql database is that azure cosmodb
supports nosql whereas sql doesn't
alright few other things about azure
cosmodb is it allows users to use key
value graph column family and document
data it also gives users a number of ap
options like sql javascript mongodb and
few others that you might want to check
the document at the time of reading and
the best part here is that all that we
mentioned we get to use only by paying
for the amount of storage and throughput
that are required and the storage and
the throughput can be elastically scaled
based on the requirement of that r all
right let's talk about
red is cache discussion about azure
database won't be complete without we
talking about redis cache now redis
cache is a secure data cache it's also
called it's also sometimes called as
messaging broker that provides high
throughput and low latency access to
data for the applications now that is
cash is based on an a popular open
source caching product which is what is
sometimes called as that is cash now
what's the use case it's typically used
to cache uh to improve the performance
and scalability of a system that rely
heavily on backend data stores now
performance when we use zach is improved
by temporarily copying the frequently
accessed data to a fast storage located
very close to the application now with
redis cache this fast storage is located
in memory with redis cache instead of
being loaded from the actual disk in the
database itself now this redis cache can
also be used as an in-memory data
structure store not only that it can be
used as an distributed non-relational
database and a message broker so there
are variety of use cases for this redis
cache and by using redis cache the
application performance is improved by
taking advantage of the low latency and
the height throughput performance that
this redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this redis cache is actually backed by
reduce server and it supports
a string hashes linked list and various
other data structures now let's talk
about security and identity services now
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principle identities you might ask
now what's a principle identity now
identity or principle identity are
services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that it can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and a security accident from happening
so let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity management are
azure security center now this azure
security center provides security
management and threat protection across
the workloads in both cloud and in the
hybrid environment it helps control user
access and application control to stop
any malicious activity if present it
helps us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
detect attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for
on-premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a unified service both for
on-premises and the cloud the next
service in security and identity would
be key vault now a key vault is a
service or a feature that helps
safeguard the cryptographic keys and any
other secrets used by the cloud
applications and the services in other
words this azure keyword is a tool for
securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment i mean the
secret keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if i tell you what keyword
actually
solves that would actually explain what
keyword is now key vault is used in
secrets management it's helped in
securely storing the tokens the
passwords the certificates it helps in
key management and it really helps in
creating and controlling the encryption
keys that we would use to encrypt data
it helps in certificate management
talking about certification management
it helps us to easily provision manage
and deploy public and private ssl tls
certificates in azure and lot more so in
a nutshell this keyword it provides
users the ability to provision new walls
and keys in just a matter of minutes all
that in a single command or all that in
a couple of button clicks it also helps
users to centrally manage their keys
secrets and policies
next in the list let's talk about azure
active directory now azure active
directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean now
this azure active directory is a cloud
based active directory and identity
management service now azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
services plus application access
management plus identity protection
and one good thing about this azure in
fact there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
this azure active directory is going to
behave now this azure active directory
is built to work on on-premises and
cloud environment as well not only that
it also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well so in a nutshell
this azure active directory it acts as a
central point of identity and access
management for our cloud environment it
also provides good security solutions
that protect against unauthorized access
of our app and the data
now that we've discussed about security
and identity let's talk about the
management tools that azure has to offer
azure provides built-in management and
account governance tools that helps
administrators and
developers that helps them to keep their
resources secure and very compliant and
again it helps both in on premises and
in the cloud environment and these
management tools help us to monitor the
infrastructure monitor the applications
it also helps in provisioning and
configuring resources it also helps in
updating apps it helps in analyzing
threats taking backup of the resources
build disaster recoveries
it also helps in applying policies and
conditions to automate our environment
we use azure management tools and it's
also used in cost control methods so
this azure management plays a wide role
across the azure services
and in the management tools first comes
the azure advisor now this azure advisor
it acts as a guide to educate us about
azure best practices it throws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of service and
it also provides the impact it can have
or the impact that would happen in our
environment if we follow the
recommendations given and
recommendations are
first one is the recommendations are
kind of templatized and it throws the
templatized recommendations not only
that it also provides customized
recommendations on the basis of the
configuration on the basis of our usage
patterns and these recommendations are
not hard it's not like something that it
recommends and then just leaves us
hanging there these recommendations
provided are very easy to follow very
easy to implement and see results you
can think of azure advisor as an a very
personalized cloud consultant that helps
you to follow best practices to optimize
our deployments it kind of analyzes our
resources our configurations our usage
and then it recommends a solution for us
that really helps in improving the cost
effectiveness improving the performance
improving high availability and
improving security in our azure
environment so with this azure advisor
we can get a proactive
actionable and personalized best
practice recommendation now you don't
have to be an expert just follow the
azure advisor and your environment is
going to be good it also helps in
improve the performance security high
availability of our environment and also
it helps in bringing down the overall
azure spend and the best part is it's a
free service that analyzes our azure
usage and provides recommendations how
we can optimize our azure resource to
reduce cost and reduce cost at the same
time boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment
next in the list would be network
watcher now this network watcher helps
users identify and gain insights in the
overall network performance and the
health of the overall environment now
these azure watchers provides enough
tools to monitor to diagnose to view the
metrics and to enable or disable logs
which means regenerate and collect the
logs for resources in the azure virtual
network so with network watcher you can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just the logs
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a vm or in a
database you know by just looking at the
logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our network we can
gain a lot of insight to the current
network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network watcher offers it also helps in
investigating vpn connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know vpn
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs and hour and stuff like that
but with the network watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix
and the next in the list would be
microsoft azure portal now this
microsoft azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment based on our
work style and using azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the azure portal
and this azure portal gives a very good
visibility on the spends that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spends
based on team spends based on days
spends based on department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual of
where the money is spending or where is
the bill consumed within the azure
environment
next in the list would be azure resource
manager now azure resource manager
enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual network
web app database servers some other
third-party services that we might use
in our environment and they are by
nature separate services but with azure
resource manager we don't see them as
different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread azure resource
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision are deployed at a constant
rate along with the other application it
also helps users to visually see their
resources and how they are connected and
that helps in managing the resources lot
better
resource group also is used to control
who can access the resources within the
user's organization kind of gives you
the fine grained control over who gets
to access and who does not get access
and the last one in the management tools
would be automation and this automation
gives us the ability to automate
configure and install upgrades across
hybrid environments
it provides a cloud-based automation and
configuration service not only that this
can be applied for non-azure
environments as well which is
on-premises
so some of the automation we could do is
process automation update management
automation configuration features
automation stuff like that and this
azure automation provides complete
control during the deployment operation
and also during the decommissioning of
the workloads and resources
with automation we can actually automate
a time consuming or mundane or any task
that's error prone because of human
errors those things can be automated so
irrespective of how many times you run
it it's gonna run the same way and that
really helps in reducing the overall
time and also the overhead cost because
a lot of the things are automated which
means it's human error-free which means
the application is not going to break
and keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the azure management tools or
management services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that azure offers
and i'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery network
now the content delivery network in
short cdn it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as load times it also helps in saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now cdns
we're going to use the word cdn here
cdns store cached content on global edge
servers also called as
pops point of presence locations that
are very close to the end users so the
latency is minimized it's like taking a
copy of the data or taking a multiple
copy of the data and storing it in
different parts of the world and whoever
is requesting it the data gets delivered
to them from a server which is very
locally to them so this cdn offers
developers a global solution for rapidly
delivering high bandwidth content to
users by caching the content in a
strategically placed location which is
very near to them so these content
delivery networks it really helps in
handling that's one advantage you get
for content delivery network that's we
can handle spikes and heavy loads very
efficiently and we can also run analytic
against the locks that gets generated in
content delivery network which helps in
gaining good insight on the workflow and
what would be the future business need
for that application and this just like
a lot of other services this is on a pay
as you go type so you use the results
first and then you only pay for what you
have used
the next one in networking would be
express route now express route is
actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to azure and because it's direct it
gives low latency link to azure it gives
good speed and reliability for the azure
data transfer it could be on premises to
azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit
now this express route is an service
that actually provides and private
connection between microsoft data center
and infrastructure in our premises or in
a different co-location facility that we
might have now these express routes do
not go over the public internet and
because they don't go over the public
internet they offer a high security
reliability and speed and low latency
compared to the connections which are in
the internet because it's fast because
it's reliable because it has low latency
it can be used as an extension of our
existing data center you know users are
not going to feel the difference whether
they are accessing services from an
on-premises or in the cloud environment
because latency is minimized as much as
possible users are really not going to
see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
a public internet line it can be used to
build hybrid applications without
compromising a privacy or the
performance now these virtual private
cloud these express routes can be used
for taking backups if assume a backup
going through the internet that would be
a nightmare if you use express route for
backups that's going to be fast and
imagine recovering a data through the
internet from the cloud through the
internet to the on premises in a time of
disaster that would be the worst
nightmare so these express routes can be
used not only to backup but also to
recover the data because it provides
good speed low latency recovering the
data is going to be a lot sooner the
next product or service we're gonna
discuss in networking is azure dns
now azure dns allows us to host domain
name in azure and these domain names
come with an exceptional performance and
availability now azure dns is used to
set up and manage dns zones and records
for our domain name in the cloud now
this azure dns is a service for dns just
like the name says and it provides name
resolution by using azure's
infrastructure and by using this domain
we can actually manage the dns ourselves
through the azure portal with the same
credential imagine having a dns provider
which does not even belong in rit
imagine that environment you know we
would have a separate portal to manage
the dns environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the dns
in the very same azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this azure dns very much integrates with
other dns service providers it uses a
global network of name servers to
provide fast response to dns queries
and these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because
most of the servers are maintained by a
microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps re-syncing let's say a server
fails it kind of helps re-syncing with
the rest of the servers so all the
microsoft's environment all the
microsoft global network of name servers
kind of ensures that our domain names
are resolved properly not only properly
but also are available most of the time
right next in the list in networking
services is virtual network i'm sure
this is going to be very interesting and
i'm sure you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment for our application
let's expand on this on this azure
virtual network
helps us to provision azure virtual
machines and it helps us to securely
communicate with other on-premises and
internet networks it also helps in
controlling the traffic that flows
through or flows in and out of this
virtual network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
azure a virtual network sometimes called
as v-net is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
azure cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customers we nets that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual network can also be used to
provision a vpns in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on-premises
infrastructure and lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using
virtual network because that's going to
require a vpn for secure data transfer
in and out of the cloud and in and out
of the on-premises environment
all right so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the azure resources
they kind of logically stay in between
or logically stay within the azure
virtual network and here we can design
the network it's given over to us you
know you can pick the ip you can pick
the routing you can pick the subnet and
a lot of freedom is given or i would say
a lot of control on how the network is
designed it's not like something that's
already cooked and we only get to use it
now we can actually build the network
from the scratch we can pick the ip
address that we like we can pick you
know which subnet needs to communicate
with the other subnet stuff like that
and like i said if you are using hybrid
environment you definitely would be
requiring a virtual network because it
helps connect the on-premises and the
cloud in a secure fashion using vpn the
last product we're going to discuss in
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
across premises virtual networks with
azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means our application will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the tcp and udp
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the backend pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains high availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
that's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in azure now azure storage in general is
a microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these azure storages are a group of
storage services they cater different
needs and the storage products include
azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes azure data lake it
includes azure files as you see it in it
includes azure queues it includes azure
tables and lot more but let's start our
discussion with azure store simple azure
store simple is an hybrid cloud storage
solution that actually lowers the cost
of storage to nearly 60
of how much you'd be actually spending
without using it so azure simple storage
or store simple is an integrated storage
solution that manages the storage task
between on-premises and the cloud
storage what i really like about azure
is that it's built around a hybrid
environment in mind there are a lot of
other cloud providers that are there
where running and hybrid environment is
a big challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on-premises and cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with the azure especially when it
comes to storage a lot of the things
that we're gonna see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable san storage area
networking solution in the cloud i
thought i'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in azure
data center and this
stores simple or simple storage it comes
along with storage steering to manage
the stored data across the various
storage media so the current the very
current data is actually stored in
on-premises on solid-state drives and
data that is used less frequently is
stored in hdds or hard disk drives and
the data that requires archived or that
needs to be archived very old data let's
say less frequently used data candidate
for archive they are actually pushed to
the cloud so you see how this storage
steering automatically happens in store
simple and one another cool feature of
store simple is that it enables us to
create an on-demand and scheduled
backups of data and and then store the
data locally or in the cloud and these
backups are actually taken in the form
of incremental snapshot which means that
they can be created and restored quickly
it's not a complete backup it's an
incremental backup and these cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recovering is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of eases
our disaster recovery steps or
procedures as well so this is store
simple it can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
data turing across the enterprise both
in cloud and on-premises it actually
improves the compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment and if there is one thing
that's increasing every new day in our
environment that would be storage and
this store simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
think in deep or having a proper storage
because now we have a simple storage
available in the cloud and moreover it's
on a pay-as-you-go type so not much
pre-planning on storage is needed yes
there will be a need but not as much as
i would without the cloud or without the
simple storage and the next service
under storage that we would like to
discuss is the data lake store this data
lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this data lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
lake store and this data lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any injection speed and it kind
of collects them in one single space or
in one single place for operational
efficiency i mean operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose hadoop in azure
is very dependent on this data lake
storage and this
data lake store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or anytime you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using hadoop in the cloud in
azure we are definitely using or we will
be to the most part or the normal
procedure or the right storage to pick
would be data lake store in azure it's
designed with security in mind so
anytime we use azure storage we can be
rest assured that we are using storage
from within a data center which has or
which was built with security in mind so
this data store also uses azure blob
storage behind the scenes for global
scale durability and for performance
let's talk about blob storage now blob
storage provides large amount of storage
and scalability now this blob storage is
the object storage solution for azure
cloud let's expand a bit on blob storage
azure blob storage is microsoft offering
for object storage now this blob storage
is optimized for storing massive amount
of unstructured data which could be text
or binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for rapid reads if i explain
to you on what scenarios we would be
using blob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or its design as
of now it's being used in many idea
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of features can fetch data
from azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of disaster
recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud id
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point i
can roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the user's storage need it
also supports tiering of the data so
based on need when i actually explore i
would find a lot of options i can pick
from that you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like i said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be queue storage now queue storage
provides durable cues for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workers let's expand this
queue storage for a moment now this q
storage is a service for storing large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere in the world through http
and https calls a single queue or a
single cube message can be up to like 24
kb in size and a single queue can
contain millions of such 24 kb in size
messages and how much can it hold it can
hold up to the total capacity of the
storage account itself so that's kind of
easy to translate how much would it hold
and this azure queue storage it provides
an messaging solution between
applications and components in the cloud
what does it help it helps in designing
an application for scale it helps in
decoupling in the application so you
know it's not very dependent or
sometimes it's not at all dependent on
the other application because now we
have a queue in between which kind of
translates or which kind of connects or
which kind of decouples both the
environment now we have a queue in
between both the environment can scale
up or scale down independently the next
in the storage service would be file
storage let's talk about file storage
now these azure files provide secure
simple and managed cloud file shares now
with file share in the cloud it actually
extends the user servers on-premises
performance and capacity and a lot of
familiar tools for the cloud file share
management can be used along with the
file storage that we're talking about so
let's expand a bit on file storage now
this azure files or azure file storage
offers a fully managed file shares in
the cloud that can be accessed via the
smb protocol server message block
protocol now this azure file shares can
be mounted concurrently by cloud or in
on-premises deployments a lot of
operating systems are compatible with it
windows are compatible linux is
compatible mac os is compatible in
addition to all this being able to run
on on premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from on premises and on
the cloud it can also offer cash for
caching the data and keeping it locally
so it's immediately available when
needed so that's some additional feature
i would say that's an advanced feature
that it offers compared to the other
file shares available in the market
let's talk about table storage let's
talk about table storage now table
storage is a no sequel key value pair
storage for quick deployments with the
large semi-structured data sets the
difference between one important thing
to note with table storage is that it
has a flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a nosql type table
storage is the one we'll end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema-less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of
data it's a lot cheaper when you compare
it with the traditional sql data or data
storage so some of the things that we
can store in the table storage are of
course they're going to be flexible data
sheets such as user data for web
application address books device
information and other types of metadata
for our service requirements and it can
have any number of tables up to the
capacity limit of the storage account
now this is not possible with sql this
is only possible with nosql especially
with table storage in azure explanation
of storage really concluded the length
and breadth of the explanation this ceo
was giving his id personal but this id
personal is not done with it yet he
still has a question even after this
lengthy discussion and his question was
well there are a lot of other cloud
providers available what made you
specifically choose azure i mean from
the kind of question that he asked we
can say that he is very curious and uh
he definitely had asked and very
thoughtful question so his ceo went on
and started to explain about the other
capabilities of azure or how it kind of
outruns the rest of the cloud providers
so he started or he again started his
discussion but from different angle now
so he started to explain what are the
capabilities or how azure is better than
the competitors so he started with
explaining the platform as a service
capabilities and i'm going to tell you
what the ceo told his id person so this
platform as a service or in platform as
a service the infrastructure management
is completely taken care by uh microsoft
allowing users to focus completely on
the innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and azure especially is a dotnet
friendly azure supports the.net
programming language and it has or it is
built or designed or it is optimized to
work with old and the new applications
deployed using net programming framework
so if your application is a.net most of
the time you would end up picking azure
i mean if you try to compare most of the
time you would end up picking azure as
your cloud service provider and the
security offerings that azure offers is
it's designed based on the security
development uh life cycle which is an
industry leading assurance process when
we buy services from azure it assures
that the environment is designed based
on security development life cycle and
like i mentioned many times in the past
and i would like to mention it again
azure has well thought about
the hybrid environments which a lot of
other cloud providers have failed so
it's very easy to set up and hybrid
environment to migrate the data or not
to migrate the data and still run a
hybrid environment they work seamlessly
with
azure because azure provides seamless
connection across on-premises data
centers and the public cloud it also has
a very gentle
learning curve if you look at the
documentation it's picture rich and the
documentations are neat and clear would
really it would encourage you to learn
more it would encourage you to think and
imagine and try easily get a grasp of
how services work so it has a very
gentle learning curve azure allows the
utilization of technologies that several
businesses have used for years so there
is a big history behind it it has a very
gentle learning curve the certifications
the documentations at the stage by stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the ctos
or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using microsoft software they can
definitely go and avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall azure spending in other words
overall a pricing of the azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the ceo pick azure as his
cloud service provider and then the ceo
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using azure
and they are definitely using azure for
a reason like pixar boeing samsung
easyjet xerox bmw 3m they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely run operate their i.t in azure
and this ceo has a thought that his id
person is still not very convinced
unless and until he shows him a visual
of how easy things are in azure so he
goes on and explains about a practical
application of azure which is what
exactly i'm going to show you as well
all right a quick project on building an
azure app using or building a dotnet
application in azure web app and making
it connect to an sql database will
solidify all the knowledge that we have
gained so far so this is what we're
gonna do i have an azure account open as
you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to resource group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right i'm logged in and
this is what we're gonna do so we're
gonna create an application like this
which is nothing but an to-do
application a to-do list application
which is going to run from the web app
get information from us and save it in
the database that's connected to it so
you can already see it's a two-tiered
application
web
and db all right so let me go back to my
azure account the first thing is to
create an resource group let's give it
an a meaningful name let's call it azure
simply learn all right and it's going to
be a free trial and the location
pick one that's nearest to you or you
know wherever you want to launch your
application now for this use case i'm
going to pick central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and and a
separate sql database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on add
it's not the web app plus sql that we
want we want web app alone for this
example so let's create and web app
uh give it a quick name let's call it
azure
simply learn
the subscription is free trial and i'm
going to use my existing resource group
a resource group that we created some
time back it's going to run out of
windows and we're going to publish the
code all set we can create it all right
while this is running
let me create my database
right sql database create a database
give it a name let's call it azure
simply learn db
put it in our existing resource group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some
settings like
the name of the server
and the admin login the password that
goes along and in which location this is
going to be created the server name is
going to be azure simply learn db that's
the server name and the admin login can
be
what can be the admin login name let's
see
so let's call it simply learn that's my
admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an web app and we
have created an
a database in
the resource group that we have created
so if i go to resource group it's going
to take some time before things show up
so if i go to my resource group i only
have one resource group as of now azure
simply learn and there i have a bunch of
resources
being created and it's still being
created right in the meantime
i have my application right here that's
running out of
or that's in visual studio as of now
right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready
in the azure console we're going to go
back to visual studio
feed these inputs in the visual studio
so the code knows what the database is
the the credentials to log into the
database and stuff like that so we're
going to feed those information in
visual studio by that we're actually
feeding it into the application and then
we're going to run it from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while
we really got to be patient right now we
have all the resources that we need for
the application to run here is my
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is
create and firewall exception rule so
one more thing needed is to create and
firewall exception rule right so the
application is going to run from my
local desktop and it's going to connect
to the
database right so let's add an exception
rule by simply adding the client id it's
going to pick my ip the ipf laptop i'm
using as of now and it's going to create
an exception to access the
database so that's done now we can go
back to our visual studio i already have
a couple of
apps running or a couple of
configurations pushed from
a visual studio i'm going to clean that
up if you're doing it for the first time
you you may not need to do this
all right so let's start from the
scratch
this is very similar to
how you would be doing
uh in your environment right so we're
going to
select an existing azure app service now
before that i have logged in as you can
see i have logged in
with my credentials so it's going to
pull a few things automatically from my
azure account so
in this case i'm going to use an
existing azure app so select existing
and then click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very same resources that we created a
while back
all right we have clicked on save and
it's
running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an url
now initially the url is
not going to work because
we haven't mapped the application to the
database that would be the next thing
all right so the app has been
published and it's running from my
web app as of now
it's going to throw an error
like you see
it's throwing an error that's because we
haven't mapped
the app and the db together so let's do
that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server explorer
this is where
we're going to see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to
the resource group
right appropriator service group
which is right here
and here i have my
database azure
simply learn
database
all right it has some issues connecting
to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
all right so
we'll have to map
the database into this application
all right so let's go to the solution
explorer click on
publish
and a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our a web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection number one
all right and then click on next
this is my db connection string right
which the app is going to use to connect
to my db
now if you recall rdb was a
azure simply learn db and that's not
being shown here
so let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure
and here
let's put our db servers
url now before that let's change this to
sql server
all right and then in here
put the
db's
url so go back to azure
here is my
db or
server's name
put that here
right
the username to connect to the server
that's
right here
put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect
to our azure
portal or the azure infrastructure and
here is my
database if you recall it's azure
sldb that's the name of the database
let's test the connection
connection is good click on ok
so now it's showing up correctly azure
simply learn db that's the name of the
database
that'll be created
now it's configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again
all right so our name of the database is
azure simply learn db
and then
it's going to be
sql
server that's the data source
the
username is simply learn
and the password is
what we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate
the connection it's good click ok
now we're all set
and ready to publish
our application
again now the application knows how to
connect uh to the database we have
educated it with the
the correct connection strings the dns
name
the username and the password for the
application to connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project and once it is up and running
will be prompted with an url
to connect and
anytime
we put or we give inputs to the url
that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and i can start
creating to-do list for myself all right
so i have items already listed
i can create an entry and these entries
get stored in
the
in the database i can create another
entry
you know take the dog for a walk that's
gonna get stored i can create another
entry
uh book tickets for
uh scientific
exhibition
and that's gonna receive and put that in
the database and that concludes our
session so through this session we saw
how i can use azure services to create a
web app and
connect that to the db instance and how
those two services which are decoupled
by default which are separate by default
how i can you know use the connection
strings to make connection between the
app server and the database and be able
to create and working app i strongly
believe you enjoyed me walking you
through this session i'd like to welcome
all of you to this training video on
azure so here we have two friends having
a conversation with each other one of
them says that her company is moving all
of its physical data and migrating it
onto the cloud she says that they're
using a cloud service provider known as
azure now here's the problem she doesn't
really understand how cloud service
providers work or even how the cloud
does her friend decides to help her out
so in this video here's what we're going
to talk about first we'll talk about
what is cloud computing what is
microsoft azure what are the services
that azure offers
and then we'll have a look at a use case
where we'll be applying one of these
services to get a particular job done
now for the first question what is cloud
computing so cloud computing actually
provides a platform through which you
can access resources now these resources
include servers storage application
security and other ways you can
transform your data or get some use out
of it now at the same time you can also
store manage and process your data now
anything related to cloud computing is
made possible only with the help of the
internet now along with these things
there are several other things that you
can do with cloud computing now let's
have a look at some of the ways cloud
computing is making our lives better
firstly you have services for just about
every requirement that you have then you
get access to the newest and most
innovative technologies in the market
right now cloud computing provides
cost-effective solutions with flexible
pricing now most cloud service providers
work in such a way that you only pay for
the amount of time you use that
particular resource then you have one of
the most important selling points when
it comes to cloud computing which is
that data and applications are
accessible from any part of the world as
long as you have access to the internet
and finally you have increased
protection for your data and
applications now you should know that
there are several cloud service
providers in the market right now be it
amazon web services adobe creative cloud
google cloud platform and so much more
now among all these platforms there's
one that's growing really really fast
and that is microsoft azure now let's
ask the question what is microsoft azure
microsoft azure is actually a cloud
service platform that allows users to
build manage scale and deploy
applications by giving them access to
cloud services now these cloud services
range from creating virtual machines to
creating functions that run themselves
without having to worry about hardware
now all of this is made possible only
through the internet now here are some
things that you need to know about azure
firstly it was launched on the 1st of
february 2010 it has data centers in
more than 42 regions across the world
they also say that 12 more data centers
are in the making which helps them say
they're the only cloud service provider
that covers these many regions next
azure is preferred by 80 of the fortune
500 companies which means that the best
of the best in the market only choose to
work with azure and finally azure is the
second largest cloud service provider in
the market right now let's talk about
azure services as i told you azure
provides services for a wide range of
domains now let's have a look at some of
these domains there's ai and machine
learning compute containers database
identity management tools networking
security storage and so much more now
let's have a look at some of the
individual services within these domains
firstly you have azure virtual machines
with azure virtual machines what you get
is the opportunity to create windows or
linux virtual machines now all of this
is possible in a matter of seconds with
a large amount of customization now
let's have a look at some of its
features firstly you can choose from a
wide variety of virtual machine options
then you have a large amount of
optimization available to you for
example what size of operating system do
you want how much size do you want
allocated to it what version of the
system is it and so much more then it
provides low cost and permanent billing
now azure provides you permanent billing
which means that you're only charged for
how much time you use the service and
finally you have enhanced security and
protection for your virtual machines
next we have service fabric now with
service fabric you have a platform which
enables you to create micro services now
this also makes the process of
application life cycle management a
whole lot easier as a direct result you
can create applications with a faster
time to market it supports windows linux
on-premises or other clouds and it
enables you to do a tremendous amount of
scaling up depending on your requirement
and finally we have functions now with
functions you can build applications
with the help of serverless computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used you can
create applications in any language that
you want and the only thing you need to
worry about is the code of the
application everything other than that
that is the hardware requirements are
taken care of by azure now let's have a
look at the networking services firstly
we have the azure cdn or the content
delivery network with azure cdn what you
get is the ability to deliver your
content with reduced load times fast
responsiveness and less bandwidth now
cdn can be integrated with several other
azure services so that the process can
move at a fast rate it can handle heavy
loads and traffic spikes with ease it
also provides a robust security system
now with the content that's delivered
you can get advanced analytic data with
which you can understand how customers
are using your content next we have
express route with express route you can
connect your on-premises network to
azure through a private network now by
default this lowers latency it increases
the emphasis on reliability and speed
and it can be of great use when you have
to transfer large amounts of data
between networks now another way this
can be useful is if it's used to add
compute or storage capacity to data
centers next we have azure dns domain
name service or azure dns can be used to
host your domains on azure this provides
high availability and great performance
it provides fast responses to dns
queries by taking advantage of
microsoft's global network it also
provides high availability next we have
virtual network azure virtual network
allows the azure resources to
communicate with each other or other
on-premise networks via the internet and
all of this is kept extremely secure now
with this users can create their own
private network for communication it
provides users with an isolated and
extremely secure environment for their
applications to run now all of the
traffic stays entirely within the azure
network and it also allows users to
design their own networks
next we have traffic manager now with
traffic manager you can route incoming
traffic to improve your performance and
availability now one thing it provides
is multiple failover options so if a
particular situation goes wrong there's
always an option to consider to salvage
the situation it helps reduce
application run time and enables the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations it also helps the
people who are using it to know where
the customers connecting from across the
world next we have load balancer with
this you are provided the ability to
instantly scale applications at the same
time providing high availability and
improved network performance for users
applications it can be integrated into
virtual machines and cloud services it
provides highly reliable applications it
also allows users to secure and
integrate security groups finally we
have azure vpn gateway now this allows
users to connect their on-premise
networks to azure using a site-to-site
vpn now this allows users to connect
their virtual machine to anywhere in the
world through a point-to-site vpn and
also it's very easy to manage and is
highly available
now let's talk about the storage
services first we have data lake storage
now with this what you get is a scalable
data storage with an emphasis on cost
effectiveness and scalability now it
comes of maximum use when you integrate
it with other services so that you can
get analytics on how the data is being
used it is also integrated with other
services like the azure blob storage now
it is also optimized for big data
analysis tools like apache spark and
hadoop next up we have blob storage now
blob storage provides a storage capacity
for data now depending on how often a
particular data is used it is classified
into different tiers now all the data
that is within the blob storage is
unstructured data now it has a way of
ensuring that the data integrity is
maintained every time a particular
object is being changed or the data is
being accessed and it also helps improve
app performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption next we have queue storage
now with this you have a message queuing
system for large workloads this allows
users to build flexible applications and
separate functions not to mention with
this you can be sure that your
individual components will not fail it
also make sure that your application is
scalable
queue storage provides queue monitoring
which helps ensure that the customer's
demands are met then we have file stored
now with file storage you can perform
file sharing with the help of the smb
protocol or the server message block
protocol now this data is protected by
smb 3.0 and the https protocol in this
case like we mentioned in functions
azure takes care of all the hardware
needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on-premises performance and other
capabilities lastly we have table
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi-structured data sets and a
nosql key value store now this is used
for creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
enterprises next let's have a look at
some web and mobile services
first we have the azure search now with
azure search you get a cloud search
service which is powered by artificial
intelligence with this you can develop
web applications as well as mobile
applications now one big advantage is
that you don't have to set up or manage
your search indices azure takes care of
that and by extension it increases your
development speed the artificial
intelligence also will provide insights
and structured information that you can
use to improve the search and structured
information next we have logic apps now
with this you can create integration
solutions which can connect applications
that are important to your business now
with this you can visually create
business processes and workflows you can
integrate sas or software as a service
applications and enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within a firewall and
securely connect to services
next we have web applications now with
web apps you can create deploy and scale
web applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
windows and linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for ios
android and windows platforms one
advantage is that it automatically
scales up and down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues
offline data syncing ensures that your
applications work anyway and you can
create cross-platform applications or
native applications for ios android and
windows
next let's have a look at some container
services first let's talk about acs or
azure container services it is also
known as the azure kubernetes services
as it's a fully managed kubernetes
container orchestration service now what
this means is that it eases the process
of container integration and deployment
it also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is azure's problem to take care of and
it enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container next let's have a
look at some database services first we
have the sql database now with sql
database what you get is a relational
cloud database service now this means
that it helps accelerate your app
development and makes it easier for you
to maintain your application now sql
database is also used extensively in
migrating workloads to the cloud and
hence saves time and cost it also helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and adaptive
technologies into your database next we
have azure cosmos db now this is a
globally distributed multi-model
database service now what this means is
that with this you can create
application with support nosql it
provides a high-grade security system
has high availability and low latency
now this is usually used in situations
where you have a diverse and highly
unpredictable workload now let's have a
look at some security and identity
services firstly we have the azure
active directory now if you want to know
more about azure active directory i
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our video on the azure
active directory this is just an
introduction so with this you can manage
user identities and you can make sure
the resources are kept safe with the
help of access policies most of these
are intelligence driven now one of the
main features is that you can have
access to your applications from any
location or device it helps increase
your efficiency and helps down cutting
costs when it comes to having a help
desk it can also help improve security
and can respond to advanced threats in
real time next you have azure active
directory b2c it helps provide customer
identity and access management in the
cloud now protecting customer identity
is extremely important for an
organization and that's what azure adb2c
does now it also enables the application
to be scaled to great amounts even
billions of customers next we have the
azure security center this is basically
like a command post with which you get a
complete view of the security across
users on your on-premises and cloud
workloads so with this you are given
threat protection method that adapts to
situations and helps reduce exposing you
to threats it also has rapid threat
response and makes the process of
finding and fixing vulnerabilities a
whole lot easier next up let's talk
about monitoring and management services
so first let's have a look at azure
advisor now azir advisor is basically a
guide for the best practices when it
comes to azure now when you follow these
it improves performance security cost
and increases availability now it also
learns from how you use the services on
your configuration and usage pattern and
the adjustments that it suggests can be
implemented very quickly and easily next
we have network watcher now with this
you can monitor diagnose and understand
the working of your network now you can
monitor your network without actually
having to log in to your virtual machine
now you can also use something known as
network security flow logs to understand
the traffic pattern how much traffic is
coming towards you how much you're
giving and so much more it also helps
diagnose vpn problems that you might
have with detailed logs and finally you
have the azure resource manager now with
this you can ensure that the resources
that you have are managed and deployed
at a consistent rate now this makes it
extremely easy for you to manage and
visualize your resources that are used
in your applications or some other
requirements and you can control who can
access your resources as well as perform
actions on it and now let's have a look
at how we can use one of these services
to satisfy a particular requirement so
the friend asks that she needs one last
bit of help she wants her friend's help
to host the website on his yacht and
here's how we can do it so now we're
going to put one of these services into
action so this is the azure dashboard so
from here we are going to create a
virtual machine within which we are
going to create a website a very simple
html website nonetheless so let's get
started so first what we're going to do
is create a resource a resource group so
what a resource group is is actually a
repository of all the resources like
virtual machines or storage that you're
going to use in your project so in this
we need a virtual machine so let's get
that created so first we'll name it
demo
east us and we'll create it now this
will take a few seconds
and that's it
so now that that's done we go on add
so we're going to be using a windows
operating system so we'll just search
for a virtual machine
we select this
and create
okay so here we are going to set up
we're going to select the resource group
the one just that we just created a
virtual machine name
okay
so
storage
and name
[Music]
passwords
and then
just breeze through the rest of it uh we
can
reduce the size we need this big
and create
now that the validation is done the next
step is to
create
now this will take a few minutes
so we'll wait
and as you can see here the virtual
machine has been created we'll go to the
source
so here all we need to do is connect and
download the rdp file
let's see if we run this file and see
what happens
now this error shows up in a whole lot
of systems that i've used
so there's a very easy way to
troubleshoot this problem so here's what
you need to do now so these are the
problems as remote access to the server
is not enabled the remote computer is
turned off the remote computer is not
available on the network
so what we're going to do is go to
networking
and add an inbound port rule now we're
trying to access a computer remotely
right so to remotely access the computer
we would need to add an inbound port
rule so that's what we're going to do
right now
so we can keep the source as any port
ranges any and our destination port as
three three eight nine if you've noticed
there we'd actually have used the three
three eight nine as the inbound port and
then we change the name as three three
eight nine
and this rule is added
now after this is done all we need to do
you can see here that we refresh the
page this would be here
a new role has been added now so we'll
go to overview
and try to connect again
do the same thing again
and this time it worked so here we'll
input the name
and
our password
and that's it now we just press yes
and there you go the system has started
your virtual machine is started now in a
while the server manager will pop up
so there's some things that we need to
do so that we can host the website so
the first thing is to create an inbound
port so we'll turn off the virtual
machine for now
come back to that later first we'll go
to
a resource group
check the name of our resource
and then we'll look at all its resources
here
so here we need to find at the network
security group
and add an inbound security rule
press add we take any source any source
port range
and then we add port 80 which is the one
that we're going to use and we'll put
the name as port
we'll add the security rule
which will take a few seconds
and that's that now it's a lot now let's
go back to our virtual machine
here you go
and let's get it started
login again
and there you have it it's on again now
we'll go to server manager
so we need to add roles and features
so most of this we can just run through
we'll leave them at the default values
same
and here we need to add a web server
which is the iis so we'll select this
we add the features
next so we can add the dotnet 3.5
features as well
next
and we'll install now
now we'll wait for the installation to
finish
and now the installation is done so now
what we're going to see is if the
website can be reached i will go to the
public address which is given here so
we've come back to our original system
click
and you can see that the is page has
been created
now we need to work more to create the
html page
here's what we'll need to do to run our
website so right now what we're getting
is this the is page now let's make it
our own html page a very simple html
page from there on we can create the
website so go back to the virtual
machine and then we go to
c drive
so the is is located in a location which
is in c drive init pub
and www root so if you click on this
actually what you'll get is the page i
showed you earlier which is this one
so now we'll go to the server manager
click on tools
and find the iis manager
so we click on this
and sites now there's a default website
we can now add a new one
the site name
demo
we need a physical path we'll put it
inside the
folder we just saw which is
right here c drive
unit pub
www root within which we'll create a new
folder
for simply learn demo
i save it
and port 80
and
okay
now this is assigned to another site so
we'll change that but we'll wait for
that okay
now for this we'll just change it
click on this
so since both of them have the same port
we'll change that
go here edit binding
we change this
to something else
okay and close
so now both are different and now we can
start our website
it's already started now
now we'll start the website right click
this
manage website
and start
and that's it
now we will go to the
to the inner pub www root and we have
simply learn demo so here we will create
the
html website or the html
the document
so
next dot html
okay
open this
it's a very simple website now so
we keep it save it
so here what we're going to do is save
as
an html file but for all
all files
we close this
now to make sure this is recognized as a
dot html file
it go to view
options
here we'll hide extensions for known
file types
just rename this
[Music]
and there you have it it's a dot html
file
now let's go back
to our
original computer
and run this page
and there you have it now this is just
the initial version more work has to be
done on it but your first step is
already done and today we will be
talking about machine learning in azure
before we move on let me tell you what
azure is so azure is microsoft's public
cloud computing platform it provides you
with various services like compute
analytics networking and storage so you
can pick from these services to develop
and scale your applications or run
existing applications in the public
cloud
okay so once you log into your azure
portal and select machine learning as
your service you will be redirected to
this page now on the right hand side you
can see there's an option called my
workspace so once you click on my
workspace it will take you to a new
window which is machine learning studio
but before that let me give you a small
idea of what my workspace is so any data
that we get into our machine learning
studio we analyze it and that is
presented under my workspace now on the
left hand side you can see there are a
few options under machine learning
studio page so let me go through those
option one so the first option is
projects so project basically gives you
a list of all the experiments that we
have worked on then comes experiments
so experiments are all the programs that
you work on to create a model after that
it's web services so since azure is a
cloud computing platform we know that
all the data needs to be uploaded over
the cloud by data i mean all the
experiments that we have needs to be
uploaded over the cloud
so web services gives you a list of all
the experiments that we have and is over
the cloud so that you can access it from
anywhere then comes notebooks so
notebooks are basically space where you
can explore analytics you can create
your own code you can visualize it and
at the last you can share it with your
peers then it's data sets so the data
set gives you a list of all the data set
that you have in your azure portal now
when you click on sample these are all
the sample data set that azure has
provided as to the users
now comes trained models so while
working in an experiment you'll come to
a point where you need to train your
model so this gives you a list of all
the models that you have trained in your
azure program then at the last you have
settings so any changes that you make is
done under settings so now that we are
done with this let's go to the next half
of our azure tutorial so on the left
hand side you can see there's an option
called new when you click on new it will
open a window so this window gives you a
list of all the templates that we have
in our azure machine learning studio
okay so since we are working from the
scratch we will be working on blank
experiment so once you click on blank
experiment a new window appears
okay so let me go through the component
that we have here so on the left hand
side you have the components at the
center you have the canvas where your
experiments will take place and on the
right hand side you have properties so
today we'll be working on problem
statement which says that we need to
find out the income of an individual
whose data we don't have in our system
now let's go on to the component part
and find the best data set that can suit
our problem statement okay so we see
that we have list of data set in our
samples so the very first data set it
adopts sensors income binary
classification so we've selected data
set and drag it over to the canvas
but before that let me give a name to
our experiment so we'll give the name as
income prediction
[Music]
now once you click on adult census
income you can see there is a circle
press right click and four options
appears in front of you the first one is
download the second is visualized third
is generate access code and the last one
is notebook since we need to visualize
the data set we'll click on visualize
so once you click on visualize a new
window appears
on the left hand side you can see there
are 32 000 nodes and 15 columns that we
have in our data set but before that let
me go through all the columns that we
have here so the first one is age which
gives you a which sense about the age of
a person
then is work class so this gives you an
idea whether he's a government employee
is he working in a private sector or is
he a self-employed then is fnlwt which
is the sample weight of the field then
is the education so education is
basically telling us about his highest
degree whether is it bachelors is it
high school grad or is he a masters
then comes education number so this
gives you an idea of the number of years
he took to complete his education
then his marital status so this is
telling about a person's is he married
or whether he has never married then his
occupation so occupation is actually
important while finding out the income
so if a person is a manager then a
chance he will be earning more as
compared to others then his relationship
whether he is a husband is she a wife or
has he never married then comes sex
whether he is a male or the female then
his capital gain capital loss hours per
week so this gives you an idea of number
of hours a person is working in a week
then is native country so income varies
from country to country so getting to
know about the country is also very
important while detecting our model and
at the last we have income we see that
the income column is divided into two
halves which is above 50 and below 50.
so there are two distinct values in
income group and in cases like these we
make use of classification algorithm now
let's go to the next part which is where
we will define the fields that we need
to have for our prediction so what we do
here is we select the column
so on the search bar when you type
column under manipulation you get a list
of options from that you select column
in data set and drag it over to the
canvas now connect your data set with
select column in data set now under this
you can see there's a caution which says
that value required so you go under
properties and select launch column
selector so once you select launch
column selector window appears
so this gives you a list of all the
columns that we have in our data set
so the very first column that we have
here is h so age is actually important
in understanding the income of a person
then comes work class so the background
of a person whether he's working in a
government employee or is he a private
employee is also important for
prediction of income then comes
education
a person who has a master's degree has
more chances of earning than a person
who has a graduation degree so education
is also an important field while
predicting our income then what comes
next is occupation
after that you have country
and at the last we will work on incur
now when you press next you get back to
the same window so now that we know the
fields that we're working on our next
step is to find the algorithm that best
suits our model
okay so now that we know the fields that
we have to work on our next step is to
find the best fit algorithm for our
model so what we do here is we look at
the list of algorithms that we have but
before that we know that our data our
target value is divided into two classes
so the algorithm that we'll be working
on is a classification algorithm now
azure provides few
classification algorithm like logistic
and decision tree two class booster
decision tree so we'll be working on two
class boosted decision tree because this
gives you a high accuracy rate now let
me give you an idea of why two class
booster decision tree is taken over all
the other classification algorithm so
what happens in two class booster
decision tree is for every node that we
have here the accuracy is calculated
and once the accuracy is above our
required accuracy then only it moves on
to the next nodes so this gives you a
height so the prediction value here
becomes more and more towards the higher
side
so that the overall model will give us a
very high accuracy okay so our next step
here is to train the model so on the
search bar again just
type train and under train you can see
there's an option called train model so
drag the train model over the canvas and
connect the two cloud boosted decision
tree with this now you can see it says
that it requires a value or a data which
is obvious because it's not it does not
have any data to work on so our next
step here is to split the data so on the
search bar when you
find split it gives you an option called
split data when you drag the split data
over your canvas and connect it with
your column data
it asks you for the split percentage so
you split the data into training and
testing so eighty percent of data gets
into the training model and twenty
percent goes into the testing model so
what we do next is we connect eighty
percent of training data with the
trained model but you see there is a
value required this is because the model
is not aware of the column it needs to
train on so what we do here is we go on
launch column selector
and select the column so we need to work
on income column
so when we select column and press enter
we see that the question mark is gone
now our next step is to find the score
of the model
so what score does is it gives you the
prediction value of the model
okay so when you connect your trade
model with the score model you again see
a caution sign here this is because it
does not have idea of what it needs to
test on so you collect your testing data
with your score model
so our last step here is to evaluate the
model so on the search bar when you type
evaluate
you get an option called evaluate model
you drag the model here on the canvas
and connect it with the score model so
your model is now complete now our next
step is to save the model and run it
now once our program is executed click
on evaluate model once you click on
evaluate model and press visualize
a window will appear this shows you the
performance of the model you see that
the accuracy is 79 which is considered
to be good
now let me go through all the other
options you see there is an option
called positive label
and negative level which has been
assigned values of above 50k and below
50 kids respectively now let me tell you
what these values are so this part is
known as a confusion matrix so of all
the values above 50k true positive give
me value that are predicted correctly
and false positive give me value that
are not predicted correctly which means
that six out of all the value that we
have in positive level 666 667 have been
predicted right that is they have their
salary above 50k and 422 have been
predicted wrong
similarly they're out of all the people
that we have 840 have been predicted
wrongly that if they have salary of over
50k but have been predicted below 50k
and 4091 have been predicted correctly
now this is used to find the accuracy of
the model so what you do here is you sum
the true positive with two negative and
divide it by false positive false
negative true positive and two negative
and then you multiply it 100 and that's
how you get your accuracy now let us go
back
and run this service over the net so
when you click on setup web service you
see predictive experiments click on
predictive experiment
now our next step is to connect the web
service input that is the entry point
with the score model
so what it does is once the program is
over the cloud it directly connects to
the score model and shows us the output
so you don't have to go through all the
processes now because the machine is
automatically learning
now you save this
and press run this will execute the
entire model
so once this is done all that is left
with you is to deploy web service so
once you click on deploy web service
it will take you to the dashboard
so you see an option called test once
you click on test
it will take you to a window where it
will ask you for values so let's just
say that i have a value of person age 35
let's say he's working
in a government
his education is
bachelor's then its occupation is
manager
this country is us
so once i press next
it will give me the predicted value
telling me that he will be earning 50k
with the precision rate of 0.12
so this is how you make use of machine
learning in azure we're going to talk
about the service as your active
directory so firstly let's ask the most
important question what is azure active
directory now here we're in a situation
where we have two colleagues having a
conversation with each other so one of
them complains that he is finding a hard
time managing multiple user logins at
the same time his friend suggests that
he has a solution that the company start
using as your active directory he says
that with azure ad they'll be able to
handle multiple user logins without any
issue so just like the question in all
our minds the friend asks how is azure
active directory going to help us so to
help you understand let's think about a
scenario now you're an employee working
for an organization and you want to use
a particular service in this case sql
database so you're assigned a set of
username and password then you want to
use another service a machine learning
service again you're assigned a
different username and password and
likewise for any number of services that
you want to use so for every service
that you're going to choose you need to
be assigned a new username and password
but this becomes a huge issue for the
administrator as they have to handle a
large number of username and passwords
now if you think about a large
organization where there's more than
thousand people working you can
understand how much of a hassle it's
going to be for the administrator at the
same time it's also a really difficult
thing for you to remember that many
numbers of username and passwords it's
difficult on the user as well and that's
where azure active directory helps now
here's a scenario where we're applying
azure active directory now you're an
employee you want to use a particular
service and you're assigned a single
username and password and with this
username and password you can access all
the services that you want so there's
only one set of username and passwords
that you need to remember you can use
any of the services that you want as
long as the administrator has given you
access to it so what is azure active
directory now azure active directory is
a service that falls under the identity
domain it allows multiple users and is a
cloud-based directory and identity
management service now here's an ideal
scenario you're joining an office newly
the admin helps you sign up to whatever
services you want and you can access
these services anywhere over the cloud
so now let's talk about something
different windows 80 and azure ad now
windows 80 was the previous version of
azure 80. so now we'll talk about why we
needed to change from windows active
directory to azure active directory so
what is windows active directory now
it's an os directory service which
allows you to work with multiple systems
multiple network resources in a unified
manner now the biggest draw when it came
to windows 80 was that it had many
layers now different layers that did
different bits of work so now let's talk
about each of these layers the first
layer is adds or the windows active
directory domain services now each layer
as i said before has a different role to
perform adds allows admin to manage
information relating to user logins and
other details like when they signed up
how much they're using and things like
that the next layer is adls or the azure
data leak storage services this layer is
for allowing you to store any amounts of
data of any type or size then you have
the adfs or the active directory
federation services where you're given a
single option for sign up with which you
get access to all systems and
applications then we have the fourth
layer the adcs or the active directory
and certification services this enables
administrators to customize services and
then be able to manage and issue public
certificates and the final layer is
adrms or the active directory rights
management service and this is used for
data protection now here's where azure
active directory changed the whole game
this means that there's a large number
of layers that administrators need to
take care of now how about there was a
solution for this and as your ad is that
solution azure active directory
integrates all these five layers into
two and these are the windows azure
active directory or the waad where it
combines all the problems when it comes
to identification management which is
almost all file layers taken into one
and the windows as your access control
service enables the federation or the
division of all these services of an
organization and by division i mean
assigning each of these services to
these users so that is taken care of by
the windows as your access control
service hence as your active directory
is able to simplify a lot of the
problems that windows as your active
directory had for example the
application office 365 uses as your
active directory to manage user
identities here's how now you're an
employee who wants to access one of the
office 365 services which could be excel
powerpoint microsoft word or something
like that so you go talk to the
administrator and he gives you access to
these services with the help of a single
username and password now as long as you
have this username and password and the
administrator has given you access to it
you can use any of these services so
who's the service audience who's using
the active directory service now there
are three types of audience when it
comes to azure active directory the
first one is id administrator the second
one application developers and online
customers so the idea administrators
their main emphasis is to ensure that
the sign-in takes place they take care
of all the sign-in procedures they also
solve issues when it comes to
authentication for example to
authenticate a particular user the
problem is solved by the id
administrators then you have application
developers who use these services to
develop applications and with this they
have an easier time developing
applications as all these resources are
easily available you have online
customers who make use of services like
office 365 and other crm services and
have all their demands catered
immediately so now let's have a look at
how we can use azure active directory to
provide access to a particular
individual so if you log into the azure
account this is what you see or you go
into active directory a list of all the
people who are using or have been given
permission to use resources from azure
okay now we're going to create a profile
we need to set up his name which is john
and second name jacob
now for properties we need to determine
the source of authority which is already
active directory so that's fine
we can select a group or add them to a
particular group if we feel like it
now if we add them to a particular group
it means that they have access to all
the resources that everyone in the group
has access to earlier so we'll do that
later we'll select their directory role
or we can select it here if we need to
it could be user administrator or a
limited administrator and now we'll set
up a password we already got one and
we'll create
and that's it we have created a user now
we'll go to their profile
so
what we can see here is that you have
access to every bit of detail related to
this account so you have the name your
first name the username the object id
job info everything you can even have
other details like how often they've
signed in when did they sign up you can
check their password you can reset the
password
delete their account and so much more
now we can even add a directory role
which we saw earlier and now let's add
this person to the admin group so you
know he gets access to all the services
those people have access to and select
that's it we've added them now the other
things that you can see here there are
applications licenses devices these are
all restrictions you can add or remove
like which device you can use the system
through or with and stuff like that so
that's it and with that we've created a
user and given him access to certain
services we're going to talk about
another important as your service as
your data factory now why should you be
interested in data factory now let's
consider a scenario so here we have two
colleagues having a conversation with
each other and they say that the data
that they're generating from their
applications or products is increasing
exponentially now considering that this
data is coming from a number of
different products it'll be a bit of a
task to analyze and store all of this
data so he wonders how they're going to
manage that his friend suggests that
they use azure's data factory now what
does azure's data factory actually do
first it stores data with the help of
the data link storage now any kind of
data can be stored in the data lake
storage then you can analyze the data
you can transform the data with the help
of pipelines and you can publish the
organized data you can visualize the
data with third-party applications like
apache spark or hadoop as well now what
exactly is data factory so now let's
have a look at what exactly is data
factory now data factory falls under the
identity domain of services in the azure
catalog and is a cloud-based integration
service basically what it does is it
works on your data it stores your data
it orchestrates and automates the
movement or transformation of data it
works heavily on the data that you store
now let's see how it actually works or
how the flow of its processes are
firstly we have the input data set which
is nothing but the data that you have
within your data store the one that you
need processed then you pass this data
through a pipeline now what does a
pipeline do a pipeline basically
performs an operation on the data that
transforms it which could be anything
from just data movement or some data
transformation now data transformation
is possible with the help of usql some
stored procedures or hype now after this
is done you get an output dataset now
this output dataset will contain data
that is in a structured form because
it's already been transformed and made
structured in the pipeline stage then it
is given into linked services like azure
data lake block storage or sql now what
it does is these store information that
is very important when it comes to
connecting to an external source now
this is you know if you wanted an
example you know how in an sql server
you need to mention the source and
destination of your data now for example
consider an sql server so you need a
connection string so that you can
connect to an external device you need
to mention the stores and the
destination of your data this is how the
linked services work and finally you
need a gateway now a gateway basically
connects your on-premises data to the
cloud so you do need a client installed
on your on-premises system so that you
can connect to the azure cloud and
finally you have the cloud here what
happens is your data can be analyzed or
visualized with a number of different
analytical softwares like apache spark r
hadoop and so on so all this time i've
been mentioning that data lake is a very
important part when it comes to azure
data factory's proper functioning so now
let's talk about what exactly is data
lake now data lake is a data storage or
a file system which is highly scalable
and distributed it is located in the
cloud and works with multiple analytics
frameworks which is external frameworks
like hadoop apache and so on so now
let's have a look at it so first you
have your output data set which is data
from the mobile video web social media
so much more it is sent into the azure
data lake store and then it is provided
to external frameworks like r apache and
spark so that they can be worked on now
there are two main concepts when it
comes to data lake storage so one of
them is storage and the other one is
analytics now storage is of unlimited
size it can be petabytes terabytes
gigabytes and so much more it shows a
wide variety of data it could be
unstructured or structured data and it
can store really large files and another
concept when it comes to data lake is
analytics now how it works now here are
two examples of how analytics works when
it comes to data lake now when it comes
to analytics you can monitor and
diagnose real-time data for example data
that you're getting from vehicles or
buildings these can be used to optimize
how they work respond to certain events
or generate alerts in case something
goes wrong then you can also identify
fraudulent transactions on your credit
card or you can identify the correct the
geographical position of your card
perhaps monitor how many transactions
have been taking place on that card and
so on so now we're going to have a look
at how we can use the azure data factory
to move data from an sql database to a
blob storage on the cloud so here's what
we're going to do so first off to make a
database what you're going to need a
software known as ssms so you can find
it on google it's called you just need
to google it ssms the first thing you
can take here
and there you have it so you just need
to click here and download the file so
we i've already downloaded the file so
basically this is used to create a
database which we'll be transferring to
the blob storage so this will take about
depending on your computer speed pretty
long or little to no time i've already
downloaded it the process is very simple
just directly go on saying yes yes and
finally once installation is done here's
what we're going to do we should go into
the dashboard of microsoft azure we need
to create a data warehouse so we'll go
into all resources create a source
go to database
and select sql data warehouse there we
have it now it's very important that you
remember the names of the service of
everything that you're going to write
here because each of these become very
important later on so i've already set
up a possible set of names
youtube
it's free trial the resource is already
created
a blank database the server we need to
create a new one so
you
that you'll name it as youtube server
youtube
admin as the server admin login
the password as
all right the location does not matter
okay that's done now here the server is
done
and here we need to change how much you
want the lowest i mean how much
computation you want how much the
workload how important your workload is
so we'll put it at the lowest since we
don't require much we'll apply the rest
is normal and great
so now we're creating an sql data
warehouse so we'll wait so now the
deployment is done so we'll go to the
notification and go to the resource here
now this is done so we'll go to the ssms
which i've already opened here and then
go here
and copy this paste it here seo
authentication login which details we
have already stored here which is admin
youtube admin and the password which is
also given there
right go to options
we go to the database name which is
youtube
everything else is there
you need to change it to tcp ip
and connect
you sign in
we'll add the password
and we're going to sign in now
right
so now that that's completed you can see
that this is what will pop up so this is
the name of the server we've given as
you saw earlier you go to databases and
here you have the youtube database that
we just created right click this and add
a new query i already have a code for
this program it's a very simple program
so
copying and pasting this
now if you need the code for this
program let us know in the comments
below it's very simple what we're doing
is creating a table called demo tab with
first name clark kent and last name is
bruce main and the table that's created
will have these two rows so now we're
going to execute this
there you have it two rows have been
affected so now let's have a look at our
table
execute this line
and there you go the table's here so now
that this is done we're going back into
azure
back and we need to create a storage
account so that's where the story where
the blob storage is going to happen so
we're going to storage accounts and
click on add
so here it's a free trial resource group
is youtube
storage account name is
all um that's all okay yes performance
is standard
general purpose
you can do locally since we don't need
to be very reliable at least for this
one advance this fine
view and create
that's done and we create now we'll wait
for the deployment to finish
and that's it the deployment is done so
we'll go to the resource
and go to blobs so this is where the
storage is happening we need to create a
blob
simply
which does not exist and
okay it has been created
now for the next bit we need to create
the data factory now so
we go to
all services and search for data factory
you press add
so here we
free trial use existing
which we have youtube is us and create
so now we've created a new data factory
now we'll wait while it's being deployed
so now it's created so we'll go here and
here we click on copy data and this
opens up
okay we'll name it
our description and once now
once now okay
all right so we press next so we need to
connect to a data source so
so what you need to do is select a
secure as your sql data warehouse so
once again you could previous
here we select zero
skill data warehouse go here
search for
source
this is your subscription free trial
here youtube server
and the databases youtube
you also need to provide your username
and password i've saved it here
youtube admin
[Music]
right
okay now we can select the table which
is demo tab
next
and now for our destination so where are
we going to connect this to we're going
to assure blob storage next
destination
job subscription free trial
and simply store
now we need to name
our
name our storage path
next
all of this can be
passed on
so
here's what we're doing it copying
whatever is inside this to the azure
blob storage that's what's happening
right now
all of that is set
and
next
it's validating and we'll wait now
it's registering connections creating
database and in the end it's creating a
pipeline
so you can monitor the pipeline from
here if you feel like it
here's what we're going to find so
here's the
here's a visual representation of what's
happening
it's being copied into the blob storage
and let's have a look if it's actually
worked out we go to our database we go
into
storage accounts simply store
go to blobs
you've created a new one
and there you have it
so based on the container that you've
named there it's created a new one here
so actually i earlier created the name
called simply blob but as you can see
here as long as you name a container it
will create a folder inside which you'll
find your particular thing that you
copied and that's it you've copied data
similarly you can do a number of
multiple operations on this container on
the on the pipeline you just created
with the data factory and that's that
today we are going to learn about the
azir virtual machine so without further
ado let's get started
before getting in depth let me tell you
what's in store for today first i'll be
talking a little about azure next i'll
start off by explaining the azir virtual
machine
then i'll be focusing on few benefits of
azir virtual machine moving forward i'll
be going in depth with the azure virtual
machine components and finally we will
be looking into a demo on azure virtual
machine
all of us may have heard of azure at one
point of time but what is azir let me
explain
azir is a cloud service created by
microsoft for building testing and
managing applications and many services
through the microsoft data centers the
azir hosts web applications over the
internet with the help of these data
centers
azir is very flexible it gives an option
to have the functionality as required
you can pay as you consume switch to
azure and accommodate the business
fluctuations there is no need to worry
about the infrastructure all the time
azir is very reliable and has 24 7 tech
support
azure offers pay-as-you-go pricing and
hence it is very cost effective
staying online all the time ensures
customers or users trust azure supports
backup and disaster recovery tools
now we know what azure is and its key
benefits let's now move on to azure
virtual machine
before that let's consider a scenario
rachel had to host 10 virtual machines
at once for a project there was an issue
when her computer ram was not compatible
with the instances the computer ram was
only 8 gb and the instances that
required were 10 gb
then she says i wish there is a service
that's cost effective and also provides
extra ram memory one of a colleague
heard this and he comes up with an idea
he says can we use azure virtual machine
it has a pay-as-you-go pricing and has
disks for storage
you can pay for what you use and create
any number of instances with high
storage capacity
also if any technical difficulty arises
you can easily retrieve the files
through the backup server
so now she's happy and she wants to know
more about azure washing machine azure
virtual machine is one of the wide range
of services that azir offers to create
your instance a virtual machine is a
computer file typically called an image
which behaves like an actual computer it
runs in a window giving the user the
same experience on a virtual machine as
they have on the host operating system
itself multiple virtual machines can run
simultaneously on the same physical
computer each virtual machine provides
its own hardware like cpus memories and
other devices as your virtual machine
offers a high range of flexibility and
it maintains the physical hardware that
runs on it
let me explain some of the benefits of
azir watching machine
first we have easy development and test
azure virtual machine has a quick and
easy way to configure the computer that
is required to code and test an
application
next
agility and scale azure virtual machine
is agile and the ability to clone and
spin up multiple instances of the same
virtual machine allows us to scale
services and applications rapidly
efficiently and very cost effectively
azure virtual machine provides enhanced
performance demands for applications can
fluctuate so you pay for the virtual
machines you need and shut down the
unnecessary ones to save the cost
azir virtual machines provide extended
data center and can be easily connected
to an organization's network it is easy
to set up your redundant infrastructure
on azure and azure provides a full
disaster recovery site at a fraction of
the cost furthermore let me explain
azure virtual machine components in
details virtual machine comes under the
compute domain of azio it also offers
various services like availability sets
snapshots
disks images and many other services
like hosts
virtual machine can be clubbed with
other services like disk images
availability sets hosts and many more so
the first component and the most
important component is the operating
system the operating system creates
connections to the remote desktop
session host there are many operating
systems available like ubuntu red hat
linux windows server sent os you can
also set the operating disk size so that
the memory is not wasted the next
component is disks azure virtual
machines use attached virtual hard disks
for storage there are two types of
virtual hard disks first is an image it
is a template for creation of new azure
virtual machine then we have discs it is
a bootable virtual hard disk all durable
disks are backed up by page blobs in
azure storage therefore the disks
inherit the benefits of blob storage
high availability durability and many
more the disks are mounted as drives on
the vm the next component is virtual
network
many components operate the virtual
machines in a scalable and secure manner
virtual networks could include equipment
such as separate network spaces for
internet facing and backend servers load
balancers firewalls and more many of
these components are deployed into an
azure virtual network azure virtual
network provides many features such as
subnet ip address load balancer and
network security group another important
component of azure virtual machine is
availability sets if in case there's a
slight chance there could be a failure
in physical servers then these come into
picture so in case of such failure the
azure platform will migrate the failed
virtual machine to a healthy host to
reconstitute the vm it is highly
recommended to deploy at least two
instances of the virtual machine
and virtual machines placed on an
availability set perform identical set
of functionalities
now that we know what azir virtual
machine is let's look into the demo in
this demo first we are going to create a
virtual machine connect it and then
create a web server and modify the web
server and finally launch the web
application so let's go ahead into the
demo now so the first step is to log
into microsoft azure with your
credentials
now let's click on virtual machines and
create a new one
so i can put add
and
you can use the subscription you want
either pay as you go pricing or free
tire resource group will create a new
one that is payroll
one okay
virtual machine we can create i'm gonna
use vm
web
zero zero one
and then region i'll be using east us
then image i'll be using windows server
r2 data center
size i'll be using b1 ms
select
username
[Music]
and then password of your choice
and then i'm going to allow selected
ports and choose rdp 3389
and next
so ost step i'll be using standard hdd
and then
yeah next
so i can see a default virtual network
and a default submit in public ip as
well as default
then next
you can allow for auto shutdown but
again it's entirely your choice
i'm going to select an extension to
install and i'm going to install
microsoft anti-malware
create okay
i'm going to create a few tags now let's
go ahead with it
so i've created five tags now review
plus create
okay so everything seems good let's
create now
so the deployment is going to take a few
minutes let's wait for it
okay so that's done now let's go to
watching machine and see our watching
machine
okay so it's been deployed
now let's get into the virtual machine
and copy the ip
address then hit windows plus r
and open mstsc
and
paste the ip address and connect
let's use a different account
you have to use the administrator
account that we've created before with
the same password
click ok
now the remote desktop session host
opens
the next step is to click on server
manager
and add rules and features
click on next
select roll base of feature based
installation and click on next
then select the watching machine you've
created and next
and then we are going to select
web server iis next
sorry
next okay so it's already installed my
computer but you have to install this
then let's close this
and open internet explorer
let's type in
http
localhost yeah so now you can see the
default browser opening
let's minimize this
and let's try it here
here we have just put the ip address
i think there's an issue
okay so let's add an inborn port
networking select networking and add in
one port
let's move 480
and add
okay so it's added now let's go and
refresh it
now we can see the default web browser
opening
so the next step is to modify the web
browser let's go ahead with that go back
to your remote session host
let's go file explorer
so certain folders are created in the c
drive let's open that
it would be
under
i needed pub
so this is where the default rose is
coming from now let's make a new text
document
open that and put
hello
welcome
to this
demo
by
simply
learn
save it
[Music]
close it let's rename this as
index
dot ht
sorry mel
so this is a text document
so we need to change that
okay let's remove this
okay
that's done
now let's go back to our internet
explorer and hit f5
let's refresh this
that's trying
okay so let's
yeah so it's done
now let's go back to the previous
browser and try let's refresh
yeah that's done
hi guys a very warm welcome
so today's uh topic is azure virtual
network tutorial
let's look into what's in it for you
so we would be covering why is azure
virtual network important
what is azure virtual network is
benefits of using the azure virtual
network
components of our show virtual network
that includes the subnet routing network
security group why these components are
required to be created in the virtual
network and how to launch an instance
within the
azure vnet or the virtual network
and then we will be seeing one demo in
which we'll create azure virtual network
subnets and network security groups
so first of all let's look into why is
azure virtual network important
so why azure virtual network is required
so somewhere far away at an office a
company was struggling with few
challenges
the company got a bigger projects which
lead to the following challenges that
includes poor network connectivity
time consuming process in building
network topologies
could not divert network traffic to its
destination on time so these were a
couple of challenges the company was
facing so
the employees thought that what could be
the possible solution to these
challenges
and then we require the azure virtual
network in that case
so first of all let's understand what is
azure virtual network is
an azure vnet or a virtual network
represents your network or environment
to run vms and applications in the cloud
when it is created the services and
virtual machines within the network
interact securely with each over the
internet so virtual network you can
consider it as a virtual cloud which is
basically kind of a cloud
space virtually assigned
to the users or or to the organization
which they can dedicatedly use for their
purpose so for example if you have to
create some uh instances or virtual
machines onto the azure cloud
and you want to connect it
with the on-prem servers for example
then you might require the virtual
network in that case let's assume that
those instances that are created in the
virtual network require the
range of ip addresses that you want to
allocate to them and that is something
you can customize using the azure
virtual network how do you want that the
traffic should be routed
to your instances in the virtual network
how the firewall securities should be
applied
everything the end user can control in
the virtual network so it seems like
that you are working in your own data
center ideally you would be working on
to the azure cloud
using the virtual network
now what are the advantages of using the
azure virtual network so couple of them
are it provides an isolated environment
for your application so as i said that
it feels like it seems like
that you are working in your on-prem
environment that means within your data
center but ideally it is a virtual space
that is allocated to you which is a kind
of an isolated environment and that is
specifically designed
for your task and the activities
a generally a subnet in a v-net can
access the public internet by default so
we create a subnet inside the virtual
network which can access
the public internet so there is a public
network connectivity that is enabled in
the virtual net so that a subnet which
will be created in the vnet can be
accessed
traffic can be easily filtered from
different resources so you can have some
control list defined you can have some
security groups created and how do you
want to allow the traffic onto the
servers or the application that is
something which you can control it is a
highly secure network and the security
groups and the policies are basically
implemented by the end user so you can
design how the security should be
implemented high network connectivity so
you have a higher bandwidth as compared
to the normal internet connection you
might be having in the data center
compared to that you use the azure
network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity
it builds sophisticated network
topologies in a simple
manner and which is easily manageable as
well as there are less
troubleshooting issues that we would
encounter
now what are the components of azure
virtual network
one of them is the subnets
then you have
routing
then you have network security groups
now what do we mean by subnets
the subnet is one of the
major or a prime important component in
the virtual network so what you have to
do is first obviously you would be
creating a virtual network
inside that you can create the subnets
subnets you can consider it a logical
partitioning
virtual partitioning inside the
virtual network
subnet lets user segment the virtual
network into one or more
sub networks
for example let's assume that you're
working in an organization and in the
organization there are different
departments for every department there
should be some set of ip addresses that
you want to allocate to
the machines that the employees are
using
or
all the department should be isolated
that means they should have their own
network ids and the network addresses
allocated to their machines and in that
case what you would do is you would
create the subnets and the subnet ids
that would be allocated to those
departments
these sub networks can be separated
logically and each subnet consists of a
server so what you do is when you create
a subnet you can you can create a server
or an instance inside that subnet and
how do you want to give an access to
that instance depends on criteria or the
requirement
hence a subnet can further be divided
into two parts one as the public subnet
and the other one as the
private subnet these are the naming
conventions of the subnet then how do
you want to give the internet
connectivity depends on how the public
subnet should be interacting with the
internet and for the private subnet as
the name suggests that the internet is
blocked so that means it is completely
isolated in the virtual network
the private instances though if you want
that any instance created in the private
subnet should have the internet
connectivity or an access you can
primarily go with the nat gateways in
that case which is a network address
translation or kind of a translator
which converts the private to public and
vice versa
and that would actually enable the
internet connectivity to your subnets
then in the public instances they can
directly access the instance as the name
suggest public instances that public
subnets that means
they have the direct internet
connectivity
next component is routing and
the routing is primarily a routing rules
you can say that are applied
and those are actually applied to
the routers only so since on the cloud
we cannot have a direct router access
and hence using the routing as a
component we can define some routing
rules which are directly applied to the
router and the infrastructure
it delivers the data by choosing a
suitable path from source to destination
for each subnet azure virtual network
automatically routes traffic and creates
a route table when you create a virtual
network automatically a route table is
created and that
basically is required to route the
traffic
and that can be used by every subnet
that doesn't mean that you only have to
create a single route table in the
virtual network you can have multiple
route tables also created which can be
associated with different subnets as
well then you have the network security
groups
it is kind of a firewall that protects
the virtual machine by limiting the
network traffic
it restricts inbound and outbound
network traffic depending upon the
destination ipa transport
and the protocol so it is basically
the network security group sits on the
instances
and
or virtual machines and
they basically
define that how the traffic should be
reaching to the ports onto the virtual
machine so how do you want to open up
the ports and for which ip addresses you
want to open up the ports that is
something
the end user or the administrator has to
specify our design so they act as a kind
of a firewall rules only that protects
the virtual machines
so how to launch an instance using azure
v-net
so first of all you have to create a
virtual network so virtual network act
as a container for subnets so first
thing is that you would be creating a
virtual network then you would be
creating
subnets
which are considered as a subset within
the virtual network
so cloud instance is included in the
subnet so first v-nets are created then
the subnets are created
and then you configure the properties in
the security group
have a look at this in detail
now with respect to the virtual network
what you need to do is you have to
create a virtual network in the azure
cloud then you have to create subnets
into each virtual network which is kind
of a subset of a virtual network so you
can create one as a public subnet the
other one as a private subnet for
example
now you have to assign instances so when
you create an instance you have to
specify that what is the virtual network
for which virtual network you are
creating an instance within that virtual
network you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created
and then connect instance to a relevant
network security group so attach your
network security group to the instances
and based on the properties or the rules
that are defined in the network security
group that will be applied to the
instances within the subnets finally
configure the properties in the network
security and set the policies
as a result you will be able to launch
your instance on azure within
the virtual network
now we will be seeing one demo that how
we can create azure virtual network
subnets and the network security group
so just be there
to watch our demo on
the azure virtual network in today's
session i would be showing how you can
create the virtual networks onto the
azure
and for that you require the credentials
on microsoft azure and here you can see
on my screen that i have already logged
in into
the azure console
now what you need to do is in order to
search virtual network you can
type
and search in the dashboard
in the search bar
with respect to the virtual networks
and here you can find
the virtual network and the gateways so
what you need to do is you just have to
click on the virtual networks and then
it will give you the options
to add the components inside the virtual
networks
so let me first open up
the virtual network
right
now in theory we discussed that the
virtual network comprises of multiple
components and sub components so
primarily is that first you have to
create a virtual network
then you have to assign the ipv4 cidr
block to the virtual network
and then you create the subnets inside
the network which is a subset of the
virtual network along with that you
define the routing rules
and
likewise you create
the instances inside the subnets that
will be part of the virtual networks
so that's what we are going to do uh in
this demo so i would be adding up a new
virtual network so you can see here
there are already two virtual networks
that have been added one is the demo
v-net which is by default so when you
created the azure credentials
the demo virtual network was already
created by the azure so that it can
provide you the
default settings
and then the test one has been created
by me and that's the customized one or
you can say a non-default virtual
network
so i'll i'm going to add another
v-net and
would define
the name to it
so let's wait for
the details to appear so here you have
to define the virtual network to create
obviously we will be going with the free
trial only
and then you have to create a resource
group so
what is a resource group it is primarily
a collection of resources that share the
same lifecycle permissions and the
policies so if you have a resource group
created you can use it otherwise you can
create a new resource group so i already
have one that is the demo one i would be
using that
in the instance details you have to
specify the name of the virtual network
so
these are certain
parameters that you have to go with
while defining the name so let's say i
put something like
test
v-net
as the virtual network that i want to
create and that is you have to select a
region where you want to get that
created
so these are the available regions that
you can select i would go with
newest east
east us only and then we have to define
the ip addresses also
see so in the ip addresses uh the cidr
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks and that becomes a fixed ip
address for that vnet
so what you can do is you can specify a
range of ip addresses now whenever we
talk about a virtual network and the ip
addresses we primarily focus on the
private ips only so this is the private
ip that we are actually
talking about so i can reserve some
ip address cidr
for our vnet and that is the range of
40.0.0.0 16
i'm going to resolve so now we'll create
one subnet and
we'll name that subnet so as we
discussed that subnets are the sub
components of
the vnet
so here you can see we have already
created one
subnet with the name public subnet so
likewise we can add another subnet also
and
let's name it to something like demo
subnet right and the subnet should have
the ip address range and that ip address
range should be part of the v-net only
with inventing
so same subnet address range you would
be defining in the subnet as well so
that will be 40.0.1 dot or we can select
2.0
the rest of the things uh would be
default we are not attaching any route
table as of now so just click on ok
and here you can see
that the subnet is created
now once the subnet is created now we
are going to create a virtual machine
inside that subnet and for that we'll go
to the search bar
and here we'll type
virtual machines
now we'll create a virtual machine in
the same v-net that is the test v-net
and inside the demo subnet
so that our virtual machine gets the
private ip address from
the subnet that has been created in the
vnet itself so what you need to do is
you have to open up the virtual machines
click on add
and here
you should add a new virtual machine
so you should select the name of the
virtual machine and
the network details
where we would be defining
the v-net as well as the subnet where
the virtual machine should be created
so in the subscription we'll go with the
free tail and in the resource group
we'll go with the demo that has already
been created we'll put a virtual machine
name
something like
test
vm
and the rest of the things will be
default
so we'll quickly skip the disk check
also
now in the networking
we would be selecting
the test vnet as
our virtual network
and in the subnet we would be selecting
the demo subnet so that is the recently
one added in the test we net and we want
that our virtual machine should be part
of that subnet only
now obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public ip also
assigned since from the public network
we need to access those virtual machines
so we'll keep it enabled right and the
next
would be the default settings that we
are going to proceed with
so let's review all the configurations
and then
create your virtual machine
so here you can see that our virtual
machine has been created validation has
been passed and it takes couple of
minutes to get that updated so let's
wait for a few more minutes so that our
virtual machine is ready and primarily
what we want to look into is that our
virtual machine is created in a correct
v-net and it gets
the private ip address from the subnet
that has been part of the
vnet uh which has been defined in the
creation of a virtual machine so let's
wait for a couple of more minutes and
we'll look into the status of
the now you can see here our test
virtual machine has been created now
what we wanted to look into is that our
virtual machine is created in a correct
subnet or not and that is something
which we can validate
by checking the private ip address so it
got the private ip from the range of
the ip address that we have specified in
the subnet
now in order to access this particular
virtual machine you have to use the
public ip since
since we have to access it from the
internet so
from the private ip this virtual machine
will not be accessible
so that's the reason that when we
created a virtual machine we allocated
the public ip address also for this
instance
so that is with respect to
uh the virtual network and the
demonstration on it and how we can
create a v-net and the sub-components of
the v-net how they are associated or
interlinked with each other
and that actually creates a kind of an
isolated environment on the
public cloud which gives you the
understanding that you can work into
just like an on-prem environment today
we will discuss what should an
individual learn in the year 2021
let's wait for an ample amount of time
so that few more people can tune in
by the time please allow me to tell you
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you are the tech geek
in a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon so that
you can never miss an update from our
end
so we have a few more people now hi
everyone welcome to simply learn
so without further ado let's get started
back in the 2000s organizations were
utterly dependent on purchase servers
for their id infrastructure
these servers not only came with limited
functionality but were also very
expensive the traditional way of storing
and managing data was costly and
complicated it required a massive amount
of hardware and complex software to run
all these issues were resolved using
cloud computing rather than owning their
computing infrastructures organizations
were able to scale up or scale down
resources based on the requirement
companies providing these computing
services are called as cloud providers
according to c-sharp corner the two
popular cloud providers in the cloud
market are amazon aws and microsoft
azure
now let's take a step back and talk
about a question
what should an individual learn in the
year 2021
amazon web services or microsoft azure
though this question is tricky we need
to understand which cloud provider is
the best option to choose
now let's take a brief look at both of
these cloud providers
amazon web services is an evolving cloud
computing platform that offers various
services such as compute power storage
database content delivery and other
resources to help business scale and
grow
aws services are provided based on a
subscription basis similarly microsoft
azure provides a set of cloud services
to design create and monitor
applications on a network
talking about the general features
amazon web services was established in
the year 2006. today it holds a market
share of 31.7
whereas microsoft azure was started in
the year 2010 and now has a market share
up to
16.8 percent
amazon aws is the world's most broadly
adopted cloud platform it offers up to
165 services globally
these services are used by millions of
companies like spotify netflix facebook
bbc etc
talking about netflix the company moved
its id operations to aws in the year
2009 aws was able to solve the company's
scalability and data management issues
azure offers several services in various
categories including artificial
intelligence analytics containers iot
and many more
these services are used by many famous
companies like accenture linkedin stack
ebay and samsung
accenture chose microsoft azure to boost
productivity and provide better security
to its employees
the aws pricing model is based on an
hourly basis with aws every individual
pays only for the services that are
required for his work every person only
pays for the services he consumes
azure pricing is charged on a per minute
basis the payment system is very simple
and doesn't involve any long-term
contracts
microsoft azure is free of upfront cost
and cancellation fees and only users pay
for the resources they consume
with azure and amazon aws there are no
additional costs or termination fees
moving on to the next factor let's talk
about availability zones
availability zones are isolated data
centers with independent power and
networking these zones protect
applications and files from data center
failures
in total aws has nearly 77 availability
zones within 24 geographic regions
around the world
the company plans to establish nine more
aws availability zones and three more
aws regions in indonesia japan and spain
on the other hand microsoft azure has
many isolated availability zones these
zones are located within an azure region
and they provide fast network
connectivity azure has 44 availability
zones around the world the company is
planning to launch 12 more zones
now after discussing the availability
zones let's talk about the services the
services that i am going to compare here
come under the following domains compute
storage
database
security and finally networking
aws and azure provide a wide variety of
services with low migration costs so
that every individual can shift his or
her current traditional infrastructure
to cloud platform very easily
aws ec2 is a suitable example of compute
services
ec2 is a web service that aims to make
life easier for developers by providing
secure and resizable compute capacity in
the cloud it can be integrated to
several other services like s3 iam cloud
formation etc
azure has a small service called azure
virtual machine image it helps the
developers to develop and design
identical virtual machines in the matter
of minutes
azure virtual machines are becoming more
popular among id infrastructures these
machines let an individual create and
use virtual machines in the cloud as ias
or infrastructure as a service
virtual machines can be created using
azure portal
as your powershell and arm templates as
your cli or client software development
kits
next comes amazon s3 it is the best
example for storage service
simple storage service is an object
storage service designed to store and
recover any information from anywhere
via the internet
amazon s3 facilitates storage through a
web service interface the service
provides 99.9 durability and 99.9
availability of objects
it has the capacity of storing computer
files up to 5 terabytes in size
on the other hand azure provides a
similar service called blob storage
service
this service provides a large amount of
storage and is highly scalable
it stores an object in the tires
depending on how often the data is being
accessed
blob storage supports widely used
frameworks like java dot net bison and
node.js it is the only cloud storage
service in microsoft azure that offers a
premium ssd based object storage tire
for low latency networks
aws provides a secure cloud platform
where every individual can manage and
deploy their applications
compared to the on-premises environment
aws security offers a high level of data
protection at a lower cost for security
purposes iam is a suitable service
aws identity and access management is a
cloud service that controls and manages
aws resources securely it has no upfront
cost also gives a facility to create and
maintain services within a specific set
of users on your aws resources
in microsoft azure as your active
directory or in short also called as
azure ad is a web service which provides
mfa multi-factor authentication features
to users in order to protect their data
from cyber attacks
next is amazon rds it is a web service
designed to simplify the setup operation
and scaling of a relational database
it is simple to set up use and scale
when required by users
it provides inexpensive and resizable
capacity and automates several tasks
such as hardware provisioning database
setup patching and backups on the other
side the azure sql database
automatically updates and backups data
in order to focus on the development of
applications
not just that it also manages database
services and response to client
requirements
client requirements such as scalability
of a service data backup and high
availability of database
similarly these cloud providers have
plenty of services that help users build
and deploy their applications
effectively
moving on to the next topic let us focus
on integrating aws and azure with open
source tools
now we will explain how to build a
pipeline using jenkins along with one of
the services of amazon web services that
is the ec2 in this integration process
we have a sample pyson application
called as a docker file this docker file
will consist of a python base image
the docker file builds a pipeline in
order to create a docker image upon
pushing the code to the repository
later the new image is used to start a
new aws service on an ecs cluster
now let's have a look at how the
integration of open source tools happen
in azure in your azure cloud application
devops tools like docker maven and
jenkins can be integrated in case you
want to integrate the jenkins pipeline
go to project and create a subscription
followed by jenkins you can specify the
required filters based on your
requirement then choose your end point
for azure devops to communicate with
jenkins
so that was all about amazon aws and
microsoft azure both aws and azure are
honored to be on top of all other cloud
providers
both provide all necessary features like
scalability high availability and
security
but the moment i hear about choosing the
best one i have to say that all that
depends upon the individual business
needs
both cloud providers are the certified
ones that hold immense value in the
current cloud service market
hey guys i'm rahul and i'll be
representing amazon web services i'm
chinmayi and i'll be representing
microsoft azure and i am shruti and i'll
be representing google cloud platform so
welcome to this video on aws versus
azure vs gcp talking about market share
amazon web services leads with around 32
of the worldwide public cloud share
azure owns up to 16 of the worldwide
market share and gcp owns around nine
percent of the world's market share
let's talk about each of these service
providers in detail aws provides
services that enable users to create and
deploy applications over the cloud these
services are accessible via the internet
aws being the oldest of the lot was
launched in the year 2006. azure
launched in 2010 is a computing platform
that offers a wide range of services to
build manage and deploy applications on
the network using tools and frameworks
launched in the year 2008 gcp offers
application development and integration
services for its end users in addition
to cloud management it also offers
services for big data machine learning
and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about aws
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the united states south
america europe and asia pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more editions
in the future azure available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with osaka and zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these services follow the
pay-as-you-go approach you pay only for
the individual services you need for as
long as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and gpu now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for aws we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that azure offers azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual network gcp's vm service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services aws cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
linux and windows virtual machines azure
virtual machine service is a part of the
free tier that offers this service for
about 750 hours per month for a year the
user gets access to windows and linux
virtual machines gcp's vm service is a
part of a free tier that includes micro
instance per month for up to 12 months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or pass services for aws elastic
bean stock is an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services developed with java dot net
node.js python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and
application health monitoring the pass
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying hardware google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by developers
for hosting and building apps in google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in java or python and
store data in google bigtable and use
the google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
services aws provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or a website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
vm image is a more comprehensive image
for microsoft azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless computing services aws has
lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
back-end code and scales automatically
when required azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers first off we
have object storage aws provides s3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the internet blob storage is an azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in microsoft's cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tears depending on how often
data is being accessed google cloud
storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on google
cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
google drive google cloud storage is
more suitable for enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets amazon provides ebs or elastic
block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 vm
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have disaster recovery services
aws provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by orchestrating and automating
the replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database services
first off for aws we have rds or
relational database service it is a web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
microsoft azure sql database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of sql server databases
without changing the user's applications
cloud sql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
mysql and sql server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud sql provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database services aws provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance azure cosmos db is
microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your application's load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment target now
let's talk about the key cloud tools for
each of these service providers for aws
in networking and content delivery we
have aws route 53 and aws cloud front
for management we have aws cloud watch
and aws cloud formation for development
we have aws codestar and aws code build
for security we have iam and key
management service for microsoft azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery network and express
route for management tools we have azure
advisor and network watcher for
development tools for management we have
azure advisor and network watcher for
development we have visual studio ide
and azure blob studio for security we
have azure security center and azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have cloud cdn and
cloud dns for management we have stack
driver and gcp monitoring for
development we have cloud build and
cloud sdk and finally for security we
have google cloud im and google and
cloud security scanner now lets talk
about the companies using these cloud
providers for aws we have netflix
unilever kellogg's nasa nokia and adobe
pixar samsung ebay fujitsu emc and bmw
among others use microsoft azure so as
seen on your screens the companies that
use gcp are spotify hsbc snapchat
twitter paypal and 20th century fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these services amazon provides
enterprise friendly services you can
leverage amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources aws is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly and securely host your
applications whether an existing
application or a new sas based
application speed and agility aws
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on-premise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure microsoft azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
azure has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an it
infrastructure costs hence it's opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp google builds in
minute level increments so you only pay
for the compute time you use they also
provide discounted prices for
long-running workloads for example you
use the vm for a month and get a
discount gcp also provides live
migration of virtual machines live
migration is the process of moving a
running vm from one physical server to
another without disrupting its
availability to the users this is a very
important differentiator for google
cloud compared to other cloud providers
gcp provides automatic scalability this
allows a size container scale to as many
cpus as needed google cloud storage is
designed for 99.9 durability it creates
server backup and stores them in an user
configured location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for aws there's a limitation of the ec2
service aws provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee aws charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 per month business which
costs more than hundred dollars an
enterprise that costs more than fifteen
thousand dollars it has certain network
connectivity issues it also has general
issues when you move to the cloud like
downtime limited control backup
protection and so on however most of
these are temporary issues and can be
handled over time talking about some of
the disadvantages of microsoft azure
code base is different when working
offline and it requires modification
when working on the cloud pass echo
system is not as efficient as iaas azure
management console is frustrating to
work with it is slow to respond and
update and requires far too many clicks
to achieve simple tasks azure backup is
intended for backing up and restoring
data located on your on-premises servers
to the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal restores of servers in a remote
data center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp so when it comes to
cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of gcp it is
quite costly it is around 150 dollars
per month for the most basic service
similar to aws s3 gcp has a complex
pricing schema also it is not very
budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from google cloud
storage i would like to welcome you to
this azure interview preparation session
knowing azure is one thing having worked
on azure is another thing and being able
to answer interview questions in azure
is a totally different thing although
one helps the other it's still different
skills and our aim through this video is
to prepare you with common product and
scenario based interview questions
so why wait let's get started a common
cloud interview question is what's the
difference between sas pass and is we
all know that
software as a service is thin client
model of software provisioning where
client in this case usually is simply a
web browser providing the point of
access to software's running on the
servers now sas is the most familiar
form of cloud service for customers sas
moves the task of managing software and
its deployment to third-party services
meaning the vendor actually gets to
manage all that so
sas is software as a service involving
applications being consumed and used by
organization so it's generally using an
application and usually organizations
pay for their use of this particular
application now some examples of sas
would include office 365 salesforce is
another very good example of sas and a
lot of google apps and storage solutions
like box and dropbox are a very good
example of software as a service talking
about platform as a service or pass it
actually functions at the lower level
than sas now typically it provides a
platform on which software can be
developed and deployed now here we
develop the software we deploy the
software now pass actually provides an
abstract of much of the work dealing
with servers and giving client an
environment in which the operating
system and the server software and the
hardwares the network are managed and
taken care in other words with a
platform as a service all the things
that i've mentioned like the servers the
server software the hardware everything
is managed by the provider and we can
focus on business side of the
scalability and we can focus on
application development of our product
or the service so in short platform as a
service is a service that enables
developers to build and work with
applications without even having to
worry about the infrastructure or
management of the underlying hosting
environments and some examples of
pass in azure is
sql and azure storage talking about
infrastructure as a service i as now
this is moving down the stack even
further now we get to the fundamental
building block of the cloud service
which is infrastructure as a service i
as now i as is fully of highly automated
scalable computer resources is is full
of storage is full of the network
capability that's what i as is now is
clients have direct access to the
servers and storage just as they would
to do traditional servers but in this
case it's going to be in the cloud in
this case it's going to be more scalable
so is is very similar to what you would
do in your on-premises physical data
center but when we talk about is we get
to do everything but it's stored in the
cloud so if we need to build a
definition around is is or
infrastructure as a service provides
users with components it provides
components it does not give us a built
environment it simply provides a
component such as operating system
networking capabilities and a lot more
now this is a paid for based on the
usage and can be used to host
applications in other words this is pay
as you go type the more you use the more
you pay the less you use the less you
pay and some of the examples of is in
azure is a virtual machine that's a
great example for is and v-nets for
networking that's another good example
for is in azure another common question
in azure interview is what are the
instant types offered by azure the main
intention of this question is how well
have you understood the different
offerings in azure and how well are you
trained to pick the right offering for
the right service now one size does not
fit all and thereof there are a lot of
services in azure that under the carpet
it does the same thing but depending on
how different your requirement is we'll
have to pick the appropriate server so
this actually this question what are the
different instant types offered by azure
it's to test how well have you used the
product and services available in azure
and how well have you applied them for
the given requirement you should be
provisioning more you should be
provisioning less at the same time so
it's kind of matching the right service
to the right requirement so what are the
instant types offered by azure as you
see in the list we have general purpose
compute optimized memory optimized
storage optimized gpu virtual machines
and high performance compute virtual
machines now answering just the names
won't be enough in an interview you'll
have to go further and explain why and
in what scenario you would use general
purpose and what are the use cases what
type of servers is a good fit for a
general purpose and what type is a good
fit for compute optimized so on and so
forth and that's exactly what we're
going to do now so the general purpose
vms you know they provide a balanced cpu
to memory ratio and it's very good for
testing very good for a development
environment very good for small and
medium databases and also for low to
medium traffic web servers and some of
the use cases are like we said test
servers low traffic web servers small to
medium databases some enterprise great
applications it's also good for
relational database it's also good for
servers used for in-memory caching it's
also good for some small analytic
database very good for micro services
and if you're trying to build a proof of
concept for an idea that you just have
or just parked this is another good
server for doing proof of concepts
because you're not going to send actual
traffic to it i just want to show that
you know your idea works so general
purpose server is a very good use case
for those scenarios and the largest
instance size we can get in general
purpose is standard d64 v3 which comes
with 256 gigabit of memory and 1600
gigabit of ssd temporary storage on the
other hand compute optimized vms have an
a high cpu to memory ratio and are very
good for medium traffic web servers very
good for batch processing servers very
good for application servers now because
it's computer optimized and compute
means a cpu it's an excellent choice for
workloads that demand faster cpu but
does not need as much memory or
temporary storage virtual cpu some of
the workloads that run very well on
computer optimized are analytic
workloads gaming servers require more
cpu they run really well batch
processing are some of the applications
that can be placed in compute optimized
and by doing that we get the actual
benefit of the compute optimized
instance and the largest instance size
or the largest instance size type is
standard f72s v2 and here we get
144 gigabit of memory and
576 gigabit of ssd temporary storage in
compute optimized vms in the same lines
memory optimized to vm they offer high
memory to cpu ratio and that are great
for databases databases require more
memory so it's a great fit for database
and it's a great fit for medium to
large scale caches applications that
require in-memory analytics so this
memory optimized memory is more so it's
very good for in-memory analytics
applications and the largest instant
size we get here is standard uh
m128m and look at the uh gigabit of
memory it's 3892
gigabit of memory and
look at the temporary storage it's uh
336 a gigabit of temporary storage on
the same lines storage optimized now i
guess i don't have to explain to you
what storage optimized is used for you
might have easily guessed looking at the
flow yes storage optimized vm offer high
disk throughput and io and are very
ideal for big data
sql nosql databases data warehousing
servers large transactional databases
and lot more and some of the examples of
the applications that can be launched on
storage optimized are cassandra mongodb
cloudera redis these are some familiar
applications that can get benefited when
we run them on storage optimized and one
difference between storage optimized and
the other servers are they are generally
optimized to use the local disk on the
node attached directly to the vm rather
than using an durable disk which is
actually an remote
disk space now what does this allow this
allows for greater input outputs per
second or throughput for the workload so
that's what we get a greater throughput
at greater input outputs per second is
what we get when we use storage
optimized and the largest instance size
available in storage optimized is a
standard l32s and
the memory is 256 gigabit and look at
the temporary storage it's a
5630 gigabit of temporary storage gpu
type vms easy to guess gpu optimized vms
are specialized virtual machines
available with
multiple gpus attached to them now these
sizes are designed for or these vms are
designed for compute intensive graphic
intensive visualization workloads that
require a lot of
graphical processing unit attached to it
so in short these are virtual machines
that specialize in heavy graphic
rendering and video editing it also
helps with model training and
interferencing with the standard
nd24rs which has
448 gigabit of memory and
2948 gigabit of temporary storage and
the last but not the least but the best
last but the best is high performance
compute or azure h series virtual
machines now they are the latest in high
performance computing vms and are aimed
to handle workloads like batch
processing analytic molecular modeling
and fluid dynamics a lot of complicated
applications in this vm and this is the
fastest and powerful cpu virtual machine
with the optional high throughput
interfaces and the largest instance size
that's available is a standard l32s
which comes with the 224 gigabit of
memory and 200 gigabit of ssd temporary
storage and a third common question is
what are the deployment environments
offered by azure there are two main
deployment environments one is the
staging environment and the other one is
the production environment now in
staging environment let's talk about
staging first so when you're deploying
your web app or web app on linux you can
deploy them to a separate slot instead
of the default production slot when
running them in standard premium or
isolated app service plan tiers now the
deployments slots are actually live app
with their own host name and at a later
point that the staging environment can
be swapped with the production
environment so why do we need and
staging environment what are the benefit
of it so the benefit of deploying our
application to a non-production or
staging environment it provides a
platform to validate changes to our
application before it can be made live
in the production environment and in the
staging environment the app can be
identified using the azure's global
unique identifier also called as the
guid url and it's very very similar to
the production url except that it has a
custom name in front of it that
identifies it as the staging environment
and for production environment this is
the live
production environment that's serving
customers request that serving the
customer content now it can be slightly
different from the staging environment
in a way that the url that's used to
identify the production environment
that's more often dns friendly name like
the name of the actual service dot cloud
app.net that way it differs in case of
staging environment you have an custom
name right before it so the custom name
and then the cloudapp.net but in this
case you get the
direct service name as the name of the
url so this is live production
environment which receives and handles
and serves customer traffic another
commonly asked question in azure is what
are the advantages of scaling in azure
the actual thought behind the question
is to see
how much have you understood scaling how
much have you seen and how much have you
applied the scaling effect in the
production environment and have received
benefits in return so let's talk about
it advantages of scaling in azure some
of the advantages are we get the maximum
application performance now auto scaling
is a built-in feature for the cloud
services be it aws azure uh google and
couple of other cloud service providers
it's a built-in feature for a cloud
service a cloud service should be auto
scalable and that includes mobile
services virtual machines and
when we run our applications
on mobile services or virtual machines
the website actually gets the best
performance
during
the change in the demand again different
applications
might require different performance
needs for examples for some apps the
performance measured based on memory and
another a good example is the
fluctuating demand for example you could
have a web app that handles millions of
requests during the day and literally
nothing at the night and auto scaling
this environment auto scaling any of
these environment will automatically
scale or fatten your environment so to
receive the all the incoming traffic and
during lean period it actually gets
slimmer and slimmer so to help you with
the cost so it actually maximizes the
performance that's what auto scaling
does and like we said auto scaling
scales up and scales down based on
demand it not only scales up but also
scales down so to help you with the cost
and if you know the particular pattern
in which the application is going to
receive traffic then we can very well go
ahead and schedule scaling to our
application or schedule scaling that
infrastructure based on time if we
already know that monday to friday
that's the traffic that i would get and
it's a constant one it's not a public
facing but you know it's an internal
application so i know all the 500 users
or the thousands or the 5000 users who
will be using it so at any given point
it's just 5 000 users it's not going to
go beyond that and during saturday and
sunday literally nobody's going to be in
office so no load at all so in that case
i pretty much know how the pattern is
going to be i can go for scheduled
scaling if i know the pattern and auto
scaling like i said not only helps with
keeping the application highly available
it also helps with the cost
effectiveness of our infrastructure so
anytime there's a vm or a group of vms
running on less cpu auto scaling is
going to actually get the environment
slimmer and slimmer so we're not
unnecessarily running any resources and
paying for it if you're being
interviewed for the infrasight in azure
this is another common question that
gets asked how are windows active
directory and azure active directory
different let's talk about the windows
active directory first the non-cloud
windows active directory was the service
was released along with windows 2000
server edition and this active directory
is essentially a database that helps
organizations to organize the users
organize the computers and a lot more it
provides authentication and
authorization to the applications not
only to the applications but also to
file servers to printers and a lot of
other on-premises resources that's what
the basic non-cloud active directory
does on the other hand the azure active
directory is not designed to manage
web-based services the azure active
directory on the other hand was designed
to support web-based services that use
rest api interfaces for office
365 salesforce.com etc unlike the plain
active directory this uses a completely
different protocol so protocol wise it's
different and the services that it
support is quite different now besides
that it also has couple of other
differences as well and let's look at
them so the actual active directory or
the windows actual directory is a
directory service that facilitates
working with interconnected complex and
different network resources in a very
unified manner on the other hand azure
active directory is microsoft's
multi-tenant cloud-based directory and
identity management service and the
windows active directory has five layers
to store data to store user details and
to issue the management certifications
on the other hand azure active directory
integrates or compresses the five layers
into just two layers here windows active
directory works with on-premises servers
like applications file servers and
printers etc on the other hand azure
active directory it works on web-based
services that use restful interfaces if
you're being hired for the development
environment or for the cloud devops
support environment or even for the
production support environment you might
find yourself being asked this question
what are the types of cues offered by
azure now azure supports two types of
queue mechanisms the storage queue and
the service bus queue let's talk about
storage queue first now the storage
queue which are part of azure storage
infrastructure it provides a simple rest
based interface simple rest based get
put and peak interface it provides
reliable persistent messaging within and
between other services it follows the
pub sub model or pub sub messaging
infrastructure and it's best suited for
users that need to store more than 80
gigabit of messages in the queue it can
provide a logs for all the transactions
executed against the user's queue so
that's what we get with storage queue
and on the other hand service bus queue
the service bus queues are built on top
of broader messaging infrastructure and
they are designed to integrate
applications and applications component
that can span multiple communication
protocol so that way it differs so this
is good for applications and components
that may span multiple communication
protocols and even different totally
different network environments so in
short these service buses or the service
bus queues in azure are part of azure's
messaging infrastructure and they
integrate applications or application
components that can actually span
multiple different protocols and
multiple different network environments
it also provides and first and first out
style for delivery and the user's queue
size has to remain under 80 gigabit
another familiar question is what are
the advantages of azure resource manager
now this resource manager helps us to
manage at the usage of the application
resources this question is actually to
test how well have you tested how well
have you used resource manager and have
gotten the benefit of it this question
actually tests how easy it has become
after the introduction of resource
manager compared to
when doing deployments or when
provisioning resources without the
resource manager so let's get into the
answers for the question what are the
advantages of azure resource manager the
in short resource manager is called arm
so the arm helps deploy manage and
monitor all the resources for an
application a solution or a group so all
the interconnected application all the
interconnected services can be monitored
as group using resource manager and
users can be granted to access to
resources that they require within a
resource manager so in an account i can
have like 10 different resources created
by resource manager or a resource group
created by resource managers and i can
allow deny connection to those services
or only to those services based on
whether the user should be accessing one
and not accessing the other so that way
it becomes easy to give access to a
group of application it helps in getting
billing details for the group of
resources now which group is using more
which group is using less and which
group has contributed more to this
month's bill stuff like that so those
details can be obtained using azure zoos
manager and provisioning resources is
made much easier with the help of this
resource manager another question is how
has integrating hybrid cloud been useful
for azure well with the use of hybrid
cloud we get the best of both the worlds
so what's hybrid cloud it's nothing but
uh combining the public cloud and the
private cloud and allowing data and
applications to be shared between them
so whenever the compute or the
processing demand fluctuates hybrid
cloud computing gives businesses the
ability to seamlessly scale their
on-premises infrastructure in the public
cloud and handle any kind of
overflow in the requirement or overflow
in handling the application so it really
helps it helps it boost the productivity
of our on-premises application so with
the hybrid cloud we get a greater
efficiency with combination of azure
services a devops process and tools for
the application running in on premises
and by having an hybrid cloud
environment users can take advantage of
a constantly updated azure service and
other aws marketplace
applications for their on-premises
environment and the other benefit is
with hybrid cloud environment we can
simply deploy applications regardless of
its locations in case of on-premises
we'll have to worry about the location
but when we expand our on-premises
environment in the cloud and they can or
we can pick any of the locations and
simply deploy it in them and this
enables the applications to be created
at a greater speed what's federating in
azure sql now this question is very
specific about sql how can we scale the
sql database now this is a very good
question or a valid question or an
important question in the interview
because
many customers or companies have
not been able to meet the user demand
because they could not scale out the
databases the theory of scaling out or
adding servers to accommodate the
increased workloads and traffic
is not hard to understand but the
implications can be very complicated the
implications can be very expensive we're
well aware of scaling the web servers
that's very common but how do we scale
the database so microsoft provides the
tools and technologies so we can scale
out the database in the cloud and that's
what is called sql or
federation in azure sql so the way we
scale out the sql
database is by sharding sharding the
database so sharding actually enables
users to take advantages of the
resources in the cloud not only that it
allows users to have their own database
or a shared database amongst each other
because we're creating a highly
available database because we're having
shards in a database it actually reduces
the possibility of a single point of
failure for our database and
more importantly because we're sharing
uh because we're using federation and
azure sql it provides and cost effective
scaling of our databases by using cloud
resources or by using billing only for
the cloud resources that we have used so
no pre-provisioning no over provisioning
it provisions the right amount and we
pay the right amount let's talk about
this one what are the different types of
storage offered by azure now the
different types of storage offered by
azure are as you already know and as you
can see they are azure blob storages
table storages file storage and queue
storage so let's expand one after the
other now blob storage are nothing but a
massive scalable object storage and
that's very good for storing text and
binary data and azure blob storage is a
microsoft object storage solution for
the cloud a lot of storage is optimized
for storing massive massive amount of
unstructured data that can be in form of
text or or in form of binary data so in
short blob storage enables users to
store unstructured data and those data
can be in the form of pictures music
video files
and lot more and it stores them along
with their metadata and another
advantage or another feature benefit
that we get from blob storage is when
object is changed it is verified to
ensure it is of the latest version
number one and number two it provides
maximum flexibility to optimize the
user's storage needs and this
unstructured data is available to
customers through an url or an rest
based object storage so they are the
benefits that come along with the blob
storage table storage on the other hand
is an a nosql store for schema-less
storage of secured data now this azure
table storage is a service that stores
structured nosql data in the cloud and
because this table is schema less it's
very easy to save your data it's very
easy to adapt your
data as the need for your application
grows and this table storage is very
fast and cost effective for many type of
applications so some of the some of the
type of data that we can store is table
storage is good for flexible databases
like user data for web applications
address book
storage device information storage and
if you want to store metadata this is a
very good use case to store them in
azure table storage azure files is
another storage here it's an managed
file share for cloud or on-premises
deployment so file storage provides the
file sharing capabilities accessible by
the server messaging block protocol and
this can be accessed from the cloud and
this can be accessed from on premises as
well now here in file storage the data
is protected by smb
3.0 and https protocols and the more
important thing is azure takes care of
managing hardware and the operating
system deployments for azure file
storage so this additional file storage
can be used when we want to burst the
storage capacity in on premises so on
premises the primary and cloud is the
secondary or the extended on-premises
storage so it actually improves the
on-premises performance and capabilities
for our on-premises data center and then
we have queues azure queues it's a
messaging store for reliable messaging
between the application components so we
spoke a little about this in the
previous question so the azure queue
storage is a service for storing a large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere in the world via http or
https protocol in here
the a single message can be up to 64
kilobits in size and in a queue we can
have millions of messages and the limit
can actually go up if we have not
reached the limit of the storage account
so it's millions and millions of
requests that can be stored in the
storage tube or the queue storage so the
queue storage in short provides message
queuing for large workloads and it
enables users to build flexible
applications and separate
the functions one from another so one
failing doesn't affect the other
application which is running healthy and
this q storage it ensures the
application is scalable and less prone
to individual component failures because
they are decoupled separate now it also
helps in monitoring the queue which
ensures the customers demands are met so
q is a great place to monitor or a great
component to monitor so we understand
how much peak have you reached for a
particular application service or a
container what is text analysis api in
azure machine learning now a text
analysis is actually an cloud based
analytics api and it provides an
advanced natural language processing
over the raw text and it has got
four main functions like the sentiment
analysis or and the key phrase analysis
language uh deduction and few other
things now what do you mean by sentiment
analysis now sentiment analysis is from
the logs from the comments from the text
comments that we receive do an analysis
and find out whether that's a positive
or a negative statement now if it is a
the api the api returns and sentiment
score between 0 and 1 and 1 is positive
and 0 is negative and then in text
analysis we have
a key phrase extraction which is it will
automatically extract the key phrase to
quickly identify the main points in that
key phrase for example if you're
analyzing an text which says the food
was delicious and there were wonderful
stuff then the api returns the main
talking points of that phrase like food
food is the main talking point and
wonderful stuffs that was a main talking
point so that's another feature that
this text analysis has and then we have
language deduction in text analysis but
irrespective of what you paste it can
try to gauge and try to align it to the
120 or up to 120 languages that it
supports so i can simply take text from
the internet and i can paste it and text
analysis software is going to identify
the language and then can run phrase and
sentiment analysis on those text right
so in short text analysis is an api a
set of web services that can be used for
text analysis it can be used to analyze
unstructured statement sentiment
analysis key phrase extraction and lot
more and the results are generally
between 0 and 1 and 1 being positive and
0 being the negative sentiment there is
no much training or in other words this
is not as complicated as couple of other
text analysis softwares are available in
the market we can simply paste we can
simply upload the text and we can call
the service and it runs a sentiment
analysis on it all by itself let's look
at this question what are the advantages
of azure queue storage if you're going
to work in a development environment if
you're going to work on an environment
that
embraces devops this could be a question
what are the advantages of azure queue
storage now azure queue storage is built
to flexibly operate the applications and
separate the functions between the
applications that run large workloads so
when we design applications for scale
these applications can be decoupled so
that they can scale independently you
know a thing happening on an application
is not dependent on another application
and anything happens to an section of
the application will not affect the
other application because they are now
decoupled and connected through the
queue storage so the queue storage gives
us asynchronous message queueing for
communication between the applications
irrespective of whether they are running
in the cloud or whether they are running
in desktop or whether they are running
on premises or on mobile devices so in
short this queue storage enables message
queueing for large workloads in a simple
and cost effective and a durable manner
talking about the advantages advantages
is it provides rich client libraries for
java android c plus plus php ruby and
lot other services getting added during
every new release from azure and the
main advantage again is it enables users
to build flexible apps and separate the
functions for
bigger or greater durability again
introduction of cues into our
application it ensures our users
applications are scalable and less prone
to individual component failures meaning
one component failing is not going to
take the whole application down right if
one component fails it's just that
component that stays fails the rest are
healthy and the rest are going to
function it also helps us to monitor the
cues and ensure the servers aren't
overhelmed by sudden traffic bursts so
how much do i have in the cube kind of
determines
the traffic for my application and if
the queue is more i can always go and
auto scale my environment and the queue
is less i can always go and shrink or
make my environment thinner so it can
save cost and anytime there is more data
in the queue i can auto scale monitor
the metric and do auto scaling based on
that metric so the environment knows
that there are more data's coming in i
need to expand myself to handle that
much amount of data this is a very
common question what are the two kinds
of azure web service roles now a service
role is a set of managed and load
balanced virtual machines that work to
perform some tasks and based on
what it's going to run on top of it is
it going to run a web service or is it
going to run a worker service defines
what kind of roles that gets attached or
that goes on this virtual machines so we
have two types web role and worker roles
the web role is a cloud service role
that's configured to run web
applications developed on programming
languages technologies and majorly they
support iis internet information service
and they support asp.net php windows
communication foundation and so on so
that's web roles and these web roles it
automatically deploys and hosts
application through the users iis
internet information service on the
other hand worker roles are roles that
runs applications and service level
tasks
which generally do not require iis so
iis is actually the differentiating
factor so in worker roles iis is not
installed by default the worker roles
are mainly used to perform supporting
background process along with web roles
and do tasks automatically compressing
or uploading the images running scripts
and
or doing some changes in the database
getting new messages from the queue and
processing a lot more you know the work
the applications are the work that does
not require ies that's what this
worker role does again the main
difference between the web role and the
worker role is that the web role
automatically deploys and hosts your
application through is whereas the
worker role does not use iis and runs
our application as standalone this is
another classic question what is azure
service fabric so azure service fabric
is actually a distributed system
platform that makes it easy to pack
deploy and manage scalable and reliable
microservices and containers now service
fabric also addresses some of the
significant challenges in developing and
managing cloud native applications and
the problem that it addresses and fixes
is now developers and administrators can
avoid complex infrastructure problems
and focus on implementing
mission-critical and demanding workloads
that can be scaled and that can be
managed through the console or from the
single place in short service fabric
provides a platform that makes the
process of developing microservices and
managing application life cycle lot
easier and the advantages of service
fabric is that now we can produce
application with faster time to market
because all the worry about the
infrastructure is taken away from us we
don't have to design an infrastructure
all that we need to worry about is
simply the application and the
application life cycle again the
advantage is it supports
windows it supports linux not only that
it supports servers on premises and in
the cloud with service fabric we can
scale up our environment to even
thousand machines in just a single
command or if there is an immediate need
for a thousand machines i can
immediately scale them up two thousand
machines that's possible with service
fabric now let's look at this question
you can expect this question if the
customer is running hybrid environment
meaning having some of the applications
and on-premises and running some of the
applications from the cloud and for some
reason when classifying the application
that goes to the cloud and that stays on
premises they have decided to keep the
database in-house so in that environment
a lot of customers do that so in that
environment this is a classic and a
scenario based question a client wants
the front end of their application to be
hosted on azure in the cloud and wants
the database to be hosted in on premises
for security reasons or to have full
control on their databases how do we go
about suggesting a solution for this
customer the ideal solution in this
scenario is to use
the v-net based point-to-site vpn
solution so all the front-end
applications will be in the cloud and
they'll be hosted in a v-net and from
the v-net they'll be connecting to the
database through and point to site vpn
so the traffic and the writings and the
leads are not coming through the
internet but through a point to site vpn
link that's connecting the azure vnet
and the on-premises environment and this
model or this approach or this solution
is best suited for scenarios where there
are only a limited number of resource
that needs to be connected between
on-premises and the cloud this is a very
common question what's azure traffic
manager of course we no more running
applications on a single server we no
more running applications on or from a
single environment right the same
application is being run from multiple
environments within azure and it can be
running from azure and on-premise as
well so multiple environments between
azure and on-premises and a lot of
customers have such environment and if
you are facing an interview with such
customer this could be an ideal question
what is azure traffic manager now the
azure traffic manager is a dns based
traffic load balancer that actually
enables us to distribute traffic between
services across azure global regions and
by doing this it provides a good
availability and a good responsiveness
to the application and this traffic
manager it uses dns to direct client
requests to the most appropriate service
endpoint based on the traffic routing
logic and the health of the endpoints
that it maintains so in short this
traffic manager is a load balancer that
enables users to provide high
availability and responsiveness by
distributing traffic in an optimal
manner across the azure when we run the
same application in different regions so
some of the advantages or some of the
use cases of using azure traffic manager
is it provides a multiple automatic
failover options it also helps with
reduced downtime it also helps with the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations so one location is
not overloaded and then it helps with
users knowing from where our customers
are getting connected from that's
another big use case with azure traffic
manager let's look at this question
right this is an ideal question now
there are group of servers connected
together within an virtual network and
now we need to
move them or create a separation between
them how do you go about achieving it so
the question goes like this you need to
isolate network traffic among vms in a
subnet which is part of a virtual
network with little downtime and impact
on the user so that's the given scenario
and the best way we can do it is create
a new virtual network and move all the
vms in that subnet to the new virtual
network now this feature is not possible
with a lot of other cloud service
providers like aws and a lot of other
providers now in those environments we
might need to shut down we might need to
stop the vm create a new vm based on the
image and it's an hefty process but here
in azure i can simply move the vms from
one subnet to another virtual network
without needing for any additional
security like the network security group
i can simply isolate them if i need to
by creating a simple new virtual network
and moving the servers to the new
virtual network look at this one this is
another common question with respect to
azure what is public private and hybrid
cloud so this is really to test how well
have you understood the different cloud
offerings in the market public private
and hybrid or at least the three basic
and hybrid cloud now the public cloud is
the most common way of deploying cloud
computing applications and
it has resources like servers storage
and are owned and operated by
third-party cloud service providers like
microsoft azure microsoft azure is a
very good example of public cloud so
here every component that the user is
using is running only on azure that's
public cloud right let me talk to you
about some of the advantages of public
cloud some of the advantages is low cost
because there's no need to purchase
hardware or software and we pay only for
the services that we use in public cloud
and there is literally no maintenance
because
the service provider maintains the
environment for us and with public cloud
we have nearly unlimited scalability
meaning we can get resources on demand
and can meet our business requirements
on demand and the public clouds are very
highly reliable because they have a vast
network of servers and they ensure that
our application does not fail so there
are some advantages of public cloud
let's talk about private cloud now
private cloud consists of compute
resources used extensively by one
business or one organization now this
private cloud can be physically located
at our organization's on-site data
center or it can be hosted by a
third-party service provider whichever
the case the private cloud services and
infrastructure are always maintained on
a private network and they're maintained
on hardware and software that are
dedicated solely for one organization or
solely for your organization so in short
private cloud in azure is azure services
being run within an on-premises data
center or on-premises data center used
by the user to host systems or
applications and some of the advantages
some of the advantages is it gives more
security resources are not shared with
others so a higher level of control and
security over our resource and
application is possible and then we have
a hybrid cloud now hybrid cloud is the
best of both worlds so it combines the
features of both public and private
cloud and some of the user components
are being run on azure and others within
on-premises data center so they kind of
share the resources in other words they
kind of share the application half of
the application would be running in on
premises and half of them would be in
the cloud and they would be working in
harmony to support the application and
the business need so that's hybrid cloud
this is one another good example
question that wants to test how well you
pick services or how well have you
understood the azure products and
services and are picking the right
service for the need so the question
would go like this what kind of storage
is best suited to handle unstructured
data
there are a lot of storage options
available and the requirement here is
what or which one would you choose for
unstructured data the answer for that
question is blob storage because blob
storage is designed to support
unstructured data it works in this way
it places the data into different tiers
based on how often they are accessed
different tier means different
performance different performance means
different cost associated with it so a
lot of add-on advantages will be get
when we use blob storage for
unstructured data in addition to it any
type of unstructured data can be stored
in blob storage this is not true with
couple of other storage options that we
have in azure only with blob storage we
can store any type of unstructured data
and the data integrity is maintained
every time an object is changed in the
blob storage and the best part is the
blob storage helps increase applications
performance and reduces the bandwidth
consumption and reduces the bandwidth
consumption for that application so they
are the benefits that we get for block
storage and blob storage are the ones
that are well suited for unstructured
data and that's what your answer should
be it's really an five step process and
if you're worked and if we have done
some labs some basic labs with azure you
can easily answer this question so it's
a five step process first step is to log
into the azure the second one is to
create an
resource resource or a resource manager
and within the resource manager you will
be selecting the resource and then pick
the offering system do you want windows
or linux and within windows what's the
flavor you want or within linux what's
the flavor you want to decide on it and
then
entering the relevant information
relevant information like the
name of the
instance or the vm that we're to launch
and the password the url that goes with
it and couple of other relevant
information that goes gets itself
attached with the
vm and then select the size of the
virtual machine different size different
types available for the kind of
application and for the intensity of the
application that will be running on top
of it so select the virtual select the
size of the virtual machine review
everything whether they're good or not
if there are any changes required go
back and edit them and then come back
and launch and your vm is there for you
to start working within like three or
four minutes not even five minutes
within three or four minutes it gets
ready and you can start working on it so
it's a quick and it's a five-step
process and you should be able to answer
it easily if you have done a few labs
in azure let's now look at some
scenario-based question you've been post
with a scenario so we thought through it
and we picked some common scenario based
questions that are being asked in
interview and i thought we'll present it
for you with the answers with
explanation so you can get benefited
through it so let's look at this
question you're asked to make sure your
virtual machines are able to communicate
securely with each other to ensure
security or to have good amount of
security what would you do and the
correct and the best answer for this
would be using virtual network in azure
which enables us to communicate with the
internet securely which enables us to
communicate with the on-premises data
center in a secure fashion so the
advantage of using virtual network is
users can create their own private
network users can pick their own private
ip ranges users can create their own
subnet users can create their own
routing between those two subnets
lot more goes into that virtual network
so it's very customizable and the users
are provided with an isolated and highly
secure environment for applications it's
completely isolated from other customers
it's completely isolated from other
applications that are running in other
virtual network that we own so within
our account we can have multiple virtual
networks and one application running on
a virtual machine is completely isolated
from other applications running on other
virtual machines and of course all
traffic stays within the azure network
as your virtual machine or within the
azure network depending on how you set
up the routing if you have set up a
routing to go or reach the internet it's
going to go otherwise it's going to stay
within azure if you have set up routing
to reach on-premises then it's going to
go and reach on-premises otherwise it's
not going to go and reach on-premises
it's going to stay within the azure and
it also allows users to design their own
network like we already discussed
picking up ips picking routing you know
picking subnets you know how many
servers should be present in that
particular subnet or how many servers
should that subnet accommodate the size
of the subnet the ip ranges the netting
the masking of ips creating of vpn all
that's possible with the virtual network
so it really allows users to design
their own network and using virtual
machine is how we secure applications in
the cloud let's look at this other
scenario how do you ensure that every
time a user logs in they are not asked
to re-enter the password as part of
authentication so you really don't want
your users to re-enter the password
every time they log in to a different
application well all the applications
have their authentication mechanism in
place all of them wants to authenticate
the user before they log in ensuring the
user does not log in every time does not
mean that wiping away all the
authentication and authorization that's
present in that application you still
need that in place but how do you make
the user hassle free so they're not
asked to re-enter the password or the
same password again and again let's look
at the options available the first one
is to enable microsoft account
authentication well it's not going to
fix because with that the user will
still need to re-enter the username and
password at deploy express route it's
not going to fix either because express
route is a network level service that
connects on-premises to the cloud so
that has got nothing to do with
prompting or not prompting for password
and then we have a setup vpn between
on-premises data center and azure set up
ad domain controller in vm and implement
integrated windows authentication well
you can use the same username and
password for on-premises and the cloud
but this setup the the vpn and the ad
controller setup it's not going to stop
you asking for repeated passwords so
this is all about
using the same password in on premises
and in the cloud and this has got
nothing to do with uh
not prompting the user to re-enter the
password all right that's same password
is different from not prompting the user
to re-enter the password they are two
different scenarios so uh that is also
out of the equation and the last one is
configure ad sync to use single sign on
that's the right one so when we
configure the ad to use a single sign on
then it's going it's not going to ask
for the username and password every time
we access an application because we have
logged in and that login is going to
stay active for like 24 hours or so
depending on how you configure it and
within that time you can access a lot of
other applications and it's not going to
ask for the username and password
because you already have a single signed
on and you have signed in using the
right credentials let's look at this one
you need to ensure that virtual machines
remain available while migrating to
azure what would be the appropriate
service to use right let's look at the
options traffic manager traffic manager
is
is literally an dns service and then
let's look at the other one update
domains it again has to do with traffic
manager updating the url so now the
traffic manager gets updated and then
starts sending requests to that
particular url it's going to take some
downtime because when we update the url
they will have to be populated to all
different places and it takes time so
within that time any user trying to
access it's going to fail and then we
have express route and cloud services
express route could be the in fact it's
the right answer because express route
it's an extension of our on
and cloud environment and in this
question it really comes out from a
customer who's having an hybrid
environment so they have applications
running in on-premises they have
applications running in the cloud and
they want to have a way to migrate
applications from on-premises to the
cloud in other words kind of do a cut
over between on-premises and the cloud
and this express route is a service that
connects between on-premises and the
cloud so when you do the cut over the
traffic is now sent to the cloud instead
of being handled in on-premises in fact
the services and the application is
getting down are getting shut down in
on-premises so the request will come in
the same pattern instead of they being
handled in on-premises they are now
routed to the cloud using express route
and the api calls get addressed
or the the queries gets answered in the
cloud through the express route service
look at this question you are an
administrator for a website called web
game and you are required to validate
and deploy changes made to your website
by your development team with minimum
down time so the real question is how do
you validate the deployment changes
that's made by the development team
let's look at the options create a new
linked resource create a staging
environment for the site enable remote
debugging on the website and then create
a new website well why would you want to
create a new website just to validate
the changes and doing a remote debugging
is not going to help because debugging
only captures logs of the changes
happening it does not do anything with
validating the changes create a staging
environment could be or is the right
answer because when we have staging
environments anything that we run on
production can be run on staging
environment and any failures that would
happen in production if we simply run it
in production can be captured when we
run the application in the staging
environment so that way staging
environment is a very helpful and useful
service and that way i can catch
any errors in other words i can validate
the changes that were done by my
development team before i move it to
production and that reduces the downtime
in the production environment look at
this one last question that we have for
you it's
a standard tier application is used
across the world and uses azure website
standard tier it uses large amount of
image files so you can get it this could
be an e-commerce website which has a lot
of pictures in it and this is causing
the application to load slow how can we
handle this situation let's look at the
options given configure blob storage
with custom domain well this application
has pictures but the pictures only the
pictures is not all that the application
has all right so configuring blob
storage might not help this could be an
very interactive website and that can't
be run from blob storage let's look at
the other options configure azure
website auto scaling to increase
instances at high loads now it's the
picture that's causing issues for the
website it's not the cpu or it's not the
memory unavailable memory not enough
that's causing the application to be
slow so we need to identify what's
causing the application to be slow so
it's not the cpu it's not the memory so
configure azure for auto scaling is not
going to help and then what are the
other options let's see configure azure
cdn to cache all responses from the
application's web endpoint a cdn could
be the right answer but look at that it
says a cdn to cache all responses from
the applications web endpoint cdn is not
designed for that though it can do it
that's not the best way to use cdn to
capture all responses from the
application's web endpoint the proper
design for cdn would be to cache the
frequently used ones in other words
cache the static content which are
photos videos logos and pictures and lot
more static content that never changes
let's look at the last option configure
azure cdn to cache site images and
content stored in azure blob storage
absolutely correct so here we will have
to redesign the application to store the
pictures high quality lazy loading or
slow loading pictures because of the
high quality and the bigger size so
store them in cdn and then the content
let it be stored in azure blob storage
that's the right way of designing the
application and if we do it this
application is going to run faster or
the application is going to respond
faster to the users
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on microsoft as your full
course i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here